e
too
so we'll open the work session we have a
number of things we hope to get through
today I know there's some amendments
that representa Maguire yeah has already
informed me of
um so we have
one5 and 38 18 and Senate Bill
252 uh kind of rolled into one here and
what Melissa and Mike have put together
as a
comparison I've been talking to Chairman
Roy and some of the ranking member of
the Democrats on the criminal justice
committee and they saw the advantages of
rolling uh all of these bills into one
because there were some competing issues
as far as Financial impacts things
didn't line up well representative
Maguire has asked that maybe we go
through this line by line uh and he's
got some other things he' like to
discuss does everybody have a copy of
this
comparison
of so represent Maguire you would like
to discuss this further so here's the
thing I I understand why representative
Roy and the others think of this as one
big package all right it's it's clear
when you look at the underlying changes
how they fit together sort of like a
puzzle and I'd like to but I but some of
them are costly changes right the
magistrates in particular I think the
fiscal note is well over $2 million a
year um and then the so the question is
like our question always is are we
getting value for money right what are
we gaining by having this versus what we
have have now so I put on this little
chart
here
um oh this Springs
memories okay what do we have now in in
terms of the the big in terms of the big
issues right I think we if we can come
to agreement on the big stuff then the
line by line will go Fairly smoothly or
or maybe we LBA can do it themselves but
so what do we have now we have bail
Commissioners and judges right bail
Commissioners there's 95 of them they
work for $40 they're only paid maybe 50
to to 80% of the time depending on which
one and what district and things like
that um they typically only do PR bail
personal recognizance bail they often
don't ask for cash bail although some
may and we're told that some of them are
ill Tred right so they're they're not
always making the best decision all
right the judges on the other hand only
work Monday through Friday they do do
both per PR bail and cash bail okay um
and then the monitoring issue so one of
these things is the ankle bracelets some
counties not all do ankle bracelet
monitoring their costs are roughly $30 a
week because they all rent these these U
ankle bracelets from some service
company and then they charge for it um
I'm told that marac County just charges
the $33 they pay straford County charges
$100 I chair I talked to the
Commissioners about this and I talked to
the
the and and one of the things is the
reason why they charge $100 because the
bracelet cost $30 but there's also
monitoring involved sure and there's a
substantial amount of monitoring
involved and that's why straford
County's program has been so successful
their true cost is closer to $100 no
there's very very little profit if any
profit there in fact it actually may
still be a loss but they charge $100 to
cover the entire cost of the bracelet
and yeah and but my understanding is
marac county has five employees who are
authorized to see the the pings right
and and that's just they consider that
part of their you know their overhead or
something anyway they don't charge for
that part okay um so that's going on
with the monitoring now we also have
have no information system that allows
anybody to know who's on bail at any
given time all right the way it works is
the bail commissioner fills out a piece
of paper saying I let someone you know
Joe Smith go on bail um he's supposed to
show up at court on Thursday and he
gives that piece of paper to the court
sometime the following week and the
court takes a picture of that piece of
paper and sticks it in Joe Smith's file
okay so then when the court meets they
know that Joe Smith is supposed to be
there maybe he's there maybe he's not
and so on but but the piece of paper is
never sort of typed in so that nobody
and you know if Joe Smith gets picked up
halfway across the state nobody knows it
right because it's it's it's scanned on
a piece of paper in some file it's it's
not it's not in a system so that you can
search and and say oh this guy's out on
bail so um and I think part of the other
part of the problem is the the court so
the paper doesn't get into the court
system for days and even when it's there
the police and so on are not don't have
access to that system so all right so
that's it nobody knows when somebody's
on on bail and then secondly finally um
the the law requires that um cases be
seen by a judge judge or somebody uh
within 48 hours after the person's
arrest and weekends and holidays don't
count all right so right now somebody
could be arrested on a Friday the
weekend doesn't count they don't see a
judge till Tuesday so they're sitting in
jail after being arrested okay for for
multiple days okay all right what these
bills
do for bail Commissioners it changes the
$40 to
$50 it makes it guaranteed it's going to
be the $50 is going to be paid by the
court to the bail commissioner and then
the court will later collect it from the
person so there's some expense here I
think our Mike our fiscal note is under
a million or something for the number
you know the dead beats that won't be
paying this and we'll have to eat
it I I think it's the number I in the
back of my mind is about 800,000 maybe
for that I don't I don't know if it's
but that's the total
cost so the bail fee for $40 is
$850 and for 50 it's around a million oh
but 80% of that's going to or some
fraction of that's going to be
reimbursed by the people or not or is
this just the part
that's unreimbursed right okay so call
this this this part is a million doll
cost but everybody seems to agree that
I've talked to that that's Justified
okay so that's that is a significant
cost um they're going to have training
all right in in one of these bills uh
it's the chief magistrate who's going to
be doing the training but in in House
Bill 105 we're creating a training
coordinator so one of my amendments is
have that training done by the training
coordinator okay um and these bills give
the bail Commissioners fewer cases
because it takes a certain list of of
serious cases away from the bail
Commissioners Al together and gives them
to the magistrates okay so it's it's
like murder
and first and second degree assault and
certain other serious cases okay um
all right the Bill calls for 15
magistrates scattered around the state
they will work weekends and they can do
all cases right so all these cases that
are going away from bail Commissioners
would go to these magistrates on the
weekends and during the week presumably
they would go to judges okay all right
judges no change essentially right they
they do all cases Monday through
Friday um the monitoring Point P portion
of these bills says the courts are going
to do the monitoring okay to to me that
doesn't make sense it's the counties
that should have the responsibility and
I believe these bills don't allocate any
money to this when clearly there's
there's money involved so um where do
you get the magistrates all cases I
don't think you're correct well bail
Commissioners are still going to do the
non
felony
arrests no I
a bail commissioner is is allowed to do
all cases in the same way a judge is
magist a magistrate I mean a magistrate
so is that your question because because
well you just have magistrates all cases
well that's not quite I don't mean they
will do all cases I mean they can do all
cases they can do all case types all
case because the legislation has I think
six or seven categories that require the
magistrates to no longer bail
Commissioners to handle those more
serious
cases that's right so my my point was
case types right so so they're
authorized just like a judge to to do
cases that that the bail commission is
still will be working weekends that's I
needs to be clear they'll handle all the
non absolutely the bail Commissioners in
the new model are not going away they're
still there they'll still handle
presumably 80% of the cases or some some
large number of cases okay all right um
then there's $1.7 million to to buy the
system to give us information about bail
okay personally I I have an argument why
this is way too much money but we'll
talk about that in a minute and now this
is the key part that makes it more
expensive is right now cases P people
who are accused can be in jail for days
before going before a judge um the new
requirement is cases must be heard
within 24 hours and so this is the key
thing that causes the magistrates right
because number one we're taking cases
away from bail Commissioners number two
um we're we so therefore we need
somebody to act within 24 hours
and the judges are still not working
weekends right so therefore you need
magistrates that that's why this whole
thing is kind of a package from from the
point of view of chairman Roy Etc right
it's this part that causes that part
okay and this part is
expensive um now
so
so any question let's let's say any
questions on what we do now versus
bills represent
grassie I just have one one one question
and maybe comment um is that you're
saying as far as holding for 24 hours
and they have to have a bail hearing
before within 24 hours or or currently
they're being held for as much as 48
Hours more than that plus weekend if we
if you hold them for 40 hours that's a
cost that the counties are in curing
that we don't see if they get if they're
done within 24 hours that alleviates a
cost to the county so it would be a
savings to the local taxpayers but it's
a cost that the state would have to pick
up I think that could very well be true
so you know is there a direct tradeoff
there that the amount of money that
we're saving at the local level the
state is picking up or is it an
additional cost that the state is
picking up by doing this which is the
more costeffective is a question I have
to ask and I don't know if we have that
information or we'd be able to to know
what that information is which be
holding somebody for 48 hours or getting
them out and processed within 24 and I
don't know in in in the serious cases
that we're talking about here whether
um they they frequently get out on bail
or you know what I mean nobody gets out
on bail and murd as what I understand or
essentially nobody but but maybe for you
know CL um assault level two or
something they do you know I don't know
hello Erin krian general counsel for the
judicial branch I just quickly wanted to
mention that a bail commissioner can
bail someone on anything that is not
murder a life in prison offense or a
violation of a protective order and a
stalking abuse and neglect or domestic
violence case um so those are not
offenses where bail is very common um
and the numbers of course of murders and
life offenses in New Hampshire is
relatively
low all
right
so if we want to so so the part of this
that to me seems least valuable okay um
aside from the 1.7 million which I think
could be done with 200,000 okay where
are you getting that number from okay
I'll tell you you want let's talk about
this okay so um I'm a former software
development manager all right so I know
something about writing software and
specifying it and so on so I went to
someone I know is capable and and wrote
a spec for for an online system that
would do exactly this something that the
bail Commissioners the police the judges
the clerks everybody could have a secure
password into that would create a file
for each person that's that's in the
system that would have information about
they were arrested on such and such a
time they were bailed on such and such a
time and and so on would have their
photograph in it all that kind of stuff
so I went to somebody who's capable of
creating such a system basically a
secure website and I said could you give
me a rough idea of the cost of doing
that and so he looked at all the specs
and so on and the number he came up with
was
$224,000 okay so
$244,000 all right so let's say that
that's too low okay um it's certainly so
the number I'm coming up with is
$200,000 and it's I feel like that's
splitting the difference right it's
eight times bigger than what my
consultant says he can do it for which
is
$24,000 and it's eight times less than
what these bills these agencies want to
realistic so eron I have a question I
know when the Senate bill it had
specific dollar amounts 750,000 for the
Department of Safety and then
$986,000 for the judicial branch where
did those numbers come from thank you
very much for the question uh in in this
instance this we were having this
discussion last year and we we had an
opportunity to go to our current vendor
and get a bit and I think the some of
the costlier items were the licenses for
the software and that there was the need
for continuing support um for the
software so the initial start startup
costs were high but our annual is about
300,000 for the judicial branch I I
could not tell you what that would be
for for uh the department of safety so I
I think representative McGuire you're
you're estimate around 100,000 that is
very close to that 300,000 bid that we
have for the annual maintenance um but
we did uh at that time and subsequently
have a chance to talk with the
Department of Information Technology and
Safety and see if there were other
Alternatives because of course we know
costs are are very important and at
least at this time I I don't think we
were able to find that there was a more
cost effective alternative although um
you know certainly understand the desire
to find one so so here's why here's my
argument let's give the 200,000 to the
Department of Information Technology
let's have them put out a bid if they
can get a qualified vendor such as the
one I found um and uh if they perform
they get paid right and then we're done
um if not not okay we've delayed a year
or whatever and we can go with this you
know their vendors are way too
ridiculously expensive from from my
point of view so that's the way I would
do it is is not charge not have the
Judiciary not have the department of
safety um except to distribute this but
but to have
doit hire somebody to create this this
um secure website so that's what I'd
like to do and if it if it fails we you
know we've wasted a year but you know I
think it won't fail so all right well I
will say I don't think we can afford a
year and I'm going to caution the
division
again I see representative Lynn sitting
out here I've had communication this
morning with the chairman Roy and I
don't want to see us go too far off into
policy on this where I know this 100%
money it has 100% money but if we don't
provide enough money you're not going to
implement the policy that's my concern
and that's why I asked Aaron to come up
to let us know where these numbers are
coming from because I don't want to
jeopardize this important policy on bail
reform because we're not providing
adequate funds to make it happen one one
other point on that this particular part
of the bail reform is independent of all
the other pieces right this is an
information system we don't have it
today right what it'll do for us is
allow us to know if somebody's on the
third offense or you know they're out on
bail twice and therefore they need to be
arrested right but but we don't know
that today and and it's independent of
whether there's magistrates or whether
there's not magistrate all this other
stuff the 24 hours it doesn't have
anything to do with that so it's it's a
separate decision all
right
further comments from the
Sweeny represent you B um thank you Mr
chair
I I think that uh if we don't trust doit
it's a complete break from the way we
usually do things I mean I've worked
with doit in various contexts like over
at Public Works you've worked with them
here
I think that uh commissioner goule is an
amazing person he's fully conscious of
cost concerns for the State of New
Hampshire and I this just would be a I'm
not saying doing something different is
a bad thing but this would be kind of a
break from the way we usually uh move
forward on really important pieces of
policy like this and like you I have
some concern about delaying a year
to figure things
out so Mr Hoffman could you get a hold
of commissioner gou and ask him if he
can venture over here at some point this
morning yes I can do that I also just to
add a little bit about the current
process all executive branch agencies
are required to go through
doit and projects are required to be
competitively bid and approved by
governor and Council
um I don't know if it's helpful but you
may consider an any appropriation
language to
include funds may not be spent for any
other
purpose
um I I'll contact uh Dennis glay but
also on the county question when we do
our uh annual updates to the um what we
call get tough bills the cost to the
judicial and Correctional systems the
county provided us a a dollar amount of
about $15 to
someone uh between 105 and
$125 per day which of course depends on
the
county yes
sir
forgive me I did just want to mention
since the ongoing legislative
negotiations of the bail Bill package we
did have a i our director not me
personally did connect with commissioner
gulay about the estimates and he had
thought that they sounded about right
the ones that we got from our vendor I
don't say that to discourage you from
speaking with him personally but we have
had an opportunity to connect at the
leadership level with
doit I figur the numbers we had here
were fairly accurate that other people
have been looking at them but I just
just want to again again no disrespect
uh but I don't want to see us mck this
thing up so we interfere with this bail
reform which everybody on both sides of
the issue wants to see get done this
year and as soon as possible
so representative cambrell did you have
any questions
or thank you Mr chair um you you
mentioned the it's your vendor um but we
said it went out to a competitive bid
did the current vendor win that bid or
so is that a case of you're kind of a
prisoner to the current vendor we're
thank you for the question we're we
would have to bid it competitively it
that we're trying to get an estimate for
um the purpose of appropriating the
provision but we would have to put it to
a competitive bid and it is possible
that someone would come in lower um our
vendor knows our system is already
plugged into our system relatively well
and at least the appraisals we've gotten
have indicated that it would be a comp
bid but you are certainly right that
someone could come with a better bid in
which case we would spend
less and especially a key thing is is
this an independent new system or is it
have to hook into the their existing
system right because that makes that
that vendor be the person all right so
anyway um before we go much further I
see that inquisitive look from my friend
uh sitting in the front row represented
ly did you have anything to add or you
observe forgive me a second the only
thing I would say is this I I do not
profess to have any particularly current
knowledge in terms of the cost issue the
the only thing I would say is that um
and I would ask uh the prior speaker if
if she has a different view on this but
I think I think the idea of having an
independent system for this might be a
problem because it it seems to me that
it needs to be able to be integrated
into the current sort of case management
system um I I would think that that you
know that that would need to be in other
words if you had if you had a if you if
you developed a you know a brand new
system and let's say it worked so that
police officers could determine if
somebody was on bail from somewhere else
but that system couldn't talk
to the case management system that is
already exists for the judicial branch I
think that would be a problem that I
mean that's that's that's my sense and
EXA and again I'm not I defer to
representative Maguire in terms of the
technology because when I turn my
computer on in the morning I often have
to ask my wife you know please help me
it's it's uh it's broken down and I
can't fix it so
I so here's the problem is apparently
they're not willing to do that to to
give everyone access to their system you
see what I mean their system actually
has the piece of paper that the bail
commissioner wrote on right so so their
system actually has the information
today and it actually does sort it by by
accused right so so you would have to
allow all bail Commissioners all police
Etc to have a log into that system allow
them to query the people and then they
could see oh here's the bail sheet for
this this particular guy um and so they
don't even need any new software today
they just need that but apparently they
haven't been willing to do that right
they want a new $1.7 million thing well
you know again
I'm I I think it's it you need to be
careful there because there certainly
should the should police officers be
able to see that sure of course but
there's you know I can I can easily
understand that there may be that it
would be improper to just give the
police complete access to the system
because there are many things in the
court file that police officers should
not see um you know confidential kind of
information or things that a defendant
may have filed in camera things like
that I mean it's I guess all I'm saying
is it's complicated now you see the
reason for a separate system that that
doesn't have sensitive information in it
that just has the information in it that
is necessary for this task I agree with
you that in general having multiple
systems can be a problem but guess what
you know people use multiple websites
for all different kinds of things this
problem is solved by a separate separate
system and it's not solved by an
integrated system because they have to
go through and say okay for every piece
of paper type that's in this data who's
authorized to see it and who isn't and
all that sort of
stuff the only last comment I make is
this I and I want I I don't know the
answer to this question but I mean I
have to
assume that other states have dealt with
this issue and other states must have
and I you know I just be curious as to
what if there's been some exploration of
what other states do because I would
assume that you know Massachusetts or
Connecticut or whatever have have had
the same kind of problem and hopefully
have have solved it uh and that that's
really all I can add thank you I'm glad
to see you have the same problem with
your laptop in the morning I often
threaten to take mine outside and shoot
it
but represent Sweeney Mr I guess for me
it's kind of it becomes a a chicken in
the egg scenario where we pass a bill
that says we're authorizing up to 1.7
million for software package that will
go out to Bid And I think anybody that's
bidding on that is going to get close to
that 1.7 million uh it sort of justifies
it
self-fulfilling that they're going to
bid up to what we've authorized to bid
so I don't know but I I don't I don't
disagree with the experts here that are
saying that this is what similar systems
would cost and they got there before
putting it out to bid officially getting
in the quotes is is tough because you
can't do that until we pass the bill so
I don't know if there would be the
ability not to punt on the issue but to
pass the the legislation allow for the
bid to go out and then leave the final
authorization to
fiscal so I don't see us being able to
actually say we're going to appropriate
$1.7 million for a software pack package
and we're not going to get a $500,000 or
$200,000 proposal because that it's not
in the range that the bid is looking for
so I it's it's a tough it's a tough
quandry because you do set what the
level of bids will come in at by setting
it in the legislation and so you're only
going to get that software so I don't
have a a solution to it but that's just
my two cents
thanks representative eil um do were you
going to try to get commissioner goule
in or talk to I mean it would just be
went yeah I'm just I mean it'd be
interesting to have his input on that
because he goes through that sort of
thing all the time um because it is
challenging especially if it's a
government contract that's being let
represented grass yeah having worked on
the software field as well I I think
that you know one of the things that we
find is always a problem is when you
have different interfaces and
sometimes having a consistent interface
makes it easier for everybody to use and
if you have different vendors you're
going to have different interfaces and
what you can do is you can develop a
system that has different security
levels on it as well so that someone
that doesn't need to have more sensitive
information doesn't have access to that
more sensitive information I'm certainly
for consistency in interface because I
think we see it throughout the systems
that we have particularly if you look at
HHS when you have problems over there
communicating with each other um it it
creates um a mess uh and being able to
have and being able to ACC access
information across the system is much
better than having separate SE separate
vendors where they don't communicate or
they are unable to communicate with each
other um and you know when they say oh
yeah it's going to work but what ends
ends up happening when it doesn't work
they're pointing fingers in each other
and if it cost us a little bit more to
get consistency I would support that I'm
not saying that the $1.7 million is the
way to go I think that you know
certainly representative McGuire has
made some valid points on on his case
but the thing is is that I would rather
see consistency of interface and
information in one location rather than
divide it up into multiple
locations thanks we do have a number of
amendments I see at least two that you
have on this particular package you do
you why don't we all right we're going
to wait on this particular issue we're
going to wait until we he from the
commission let's talk about the other
big issue as I see it on the on the page
and that's the magistrates okay the 15
magistrates so um this these bills
imagine they're they're one per County
plus a few okay um and they work
weekends and they do all case types
because because bail um bail
Commissioners are being restricted right
to to fewer case types um but expensive
right each each magistrate is like
$150,000 a year person okay um so we're
adding 225,000 or so per year 2.25
million per year to the cost of the
Judiciary um what's the
alternative so the alternative
is uh number one we could
just we're we're improving the bail
Commissioners lot here right we're we're
giving them more money we're making the
money guaranteed we're getting them
better training so they'll do a better
job presumably all right so that
hopefully will attract the number 95 to
get bigger so that there will be
there'll be more bail Commissioners
there won't they won't be as uh tightly
um scheduled okay so we could just sort
of stop there
right and and say let's try that for a
year or so and then if if still there's
a
problem okay maybe add some magistrates
right that would be one
choice um another one would
be
um uh still have the bail Commissioners
tell them they can only do fewer cases
right and tell some judges you've got to
work
weekends and uh um you've got to uh but
but you could do all your stuff by Zoom
okay so that's how it's likely that's
how magistrates are going to end up
working is is by Zoom
essentially um because some of these
counties are quite large and we're
talking about one per County the
magistrates not going to be driving all
over the place like the bail
Commissioners are right so so that would
be another thing right there there's not
that many cases
maybe do we have a number the number of
cases in
the uh you know first and second degree
on the the cases that are specifically
not able to be heard by a bail
commissioner anymore under this
legislation is about 1400 a year okay
1400 a year is uh 30 a
week right so um
so so you're talking about
um a handful of Judges working Saturday
and Sunday maybe right so um I don't
know how long it takes to to decide such
a case half an
hour I don't does that sound right a lot
of speculation
yeah all right well anyways so my my
point is you know a judge coming in
somebody who's available Saturday
somebody is available
Sunday um doing it by Zoom so there's
only one in the state or two in the
state on Saturday and two on the state
on Sunday something like that um that's
another way to go okay um and it's cases
that they would be deciding anyways so
it's not like there's more cases or
whatever U not that much more work so
that's another way to go right without
magistrates and and don't spend the 2
million
you could also you could also say fewer
than 15 right take instead of those two
or three judges working weekends get two
or three magistrates working weekends
right not 15 that's another way to do it
all right but but the main thing is it
seems likely that since these
magistrates are not traveling because
because the issue is if if they go to
court if they have to go to the county
court that means you got to have a clerk
there you got to have security there you
got to have you know all that sort of
stuff opening the door on the weekend uh
those people are going to be paid
overtime and your time and a half and
all this stuff so so it has to in order
for this to work even the way it's
written now it's got to be over Zoom
right and and my
point to make it so the problem with
this is the bail commissioner is there
in person with the accused they can take
the measure of the Accused by talking to
them directly right and so making that
decision I have a hard time seeing that
the bail magistrate is going to make
that much better of a
decision meeting somebody over the phone
or over Zoom you see what I mean so I
have I have a hard time seeing that that
$2 million is worth
spending representa Griffin
please I think in your scenario one
where we expand the bail
Commissioners and guarantee the payment
and get them some
training and see how it goes for a year
or two I think that's far superior to
setting up magistrates that we have no
idea how it's going to work how it'll
work out and it's very
expensive uh I'm impressed with bail
Commissioners I met one
recently and most of them I think are
there they're volunteers really the
money doesn't mean that much to them I
mention the fact that we had a bill that
was going to guarantee the money and
they said well if you think we're doing
it for the money you're
crazy they're really good people they're
concerned about you know they they're
very diligent in their job and I'd like
to see us not just bail out on them I'd
like to see us see if we can expand it
and and make it work a little better
before we spend millions and millions of
magistrates pres of Evo um I I like to
ask one of the experts in the room
wasn't the point of the ne the intense
negotiation on this uh a point of
contention was that there was the list
of crimes was it 14 that uh people felt
in particular needed a higher level of
review and that's why they came up with
the
magistrate concept I mean that was a
point a huge point of
negotiation um because they didn't want
these bigger crimes to be handled by
bail Commissioners I'm I'm I'm seeing
nods yeah if you look at the Senate bill
Senate Bill 252 that came out there were
a number of
um crimes that are no would no longer be
handled by bail Commissioners first
degree assault second degree assault
felony level domestic violence
aggregated uh
a aggravated fonia sexual
assault fonia sexual assault
stalking drug trafficking of people
possession manufacturing uh distribution
of child sexual abuse
images and the list goes on so those are
all the items again it came out of the
Senate that would be restricted
specifically towards two magistrates
Commissioners this is one of those items
where if you pull the thread the s
letter is going to start to fall apart
and I think a lot of this uh Rose and
fall fell on the existence of the
magistrate system um I also not
recalling exactly what the
qualifications of the magistrates were
were the attorneys
orne so it's a much higher level of
review than what would be given by a
bail
commissioner further questions
representative sweenee I I seem to
recall I think the number 15 was said to
come from a previous bill in which there
were no bail
Commissioners
present uh the judicial branch did
complete a fiscal note for a previous
Bill about what we would do if we were
required by Statute to eliminate bail
Commissioners and we estimated 15 I
understand from speaking with chairman
Roy his estimate of 15 comes on
Geographic coverage most bail
Commissioners go in person to the jails
and he wanted there to be at least one
person Per County and some coverage so
the numbers are the same but and I had
originally thought he had taken that
from that previous bill but I understand
he wanted to have Geographic coverage
and that's his policy intention thank
you follow follow
conversation so I understand the need
for magistrates in order to get the
24hour case turned
around for those specific cases and 30
cases a week uh I just think I'd be
comfortable with five
magistrates and I'm thinking one per
executive Council District if we set it
up that way I do think a lot of it would
be
telecommunications of the magistrates
into the the county areas so they
wouldn't have to be physically there but
in my mind five magistrates could handle
six cases a week that gets us over the
that gets us to the 30 cases that need
to be handled and they would allow
they'd be able to work for the judicial
branch on other areas as well helping
speed up the the meeting the audit of
the judicial branch that we saw last
year for case load so I I I can't
support 15 I I'm I'd be more comfortable
with five since it seems to be the Lynch
pin to get the 24hour cases uh going and
and I think it's easier to start with a
smaller number of magistrates and if in
two years the judicial branch says it's
it's overc capacity a future legislature
can look at that but we're not going to
start with 15 and be able to scale that
back if it's not
necessary um I think that if we're going
to try to cut costs it is the number of
magistrates we should be focusing on i'
I'd be interested in what chair Roy's
idea would be I remember I asked him
specifically because we had thought
about this what he thought the bare
minimum should be and he did say 10 and
he was focused on the n number of um
counties so maybe there's a magical
number between five and 15 but it really
I I'd find a I'd be interested to just
get his feedback since he's
the he's so deeply involved in this but
look represent Maguire so I'll ask Judge
Lynn um
you've talked to me personally before
about Judges working
weekends right what what do you think
about that he's just really glad he's
retired no you know I have to say it
respectfully to who to to
everyone it the idea that judges
shouldn't work weekends is baloney I
mean they they're working weekends now I
to be to be you know I in the 27 or
almost 27 years I was at the in the
judicial
branch unquestionably the majority of of
the weekends that fell in that time I
was working at least part of the time
and sometimes both days now I wasn't
working in the court generally I was
working from home but working on stuff
but sometime it was in the court doing
you know not doing hearings but doing
doing research or writing or being at
the library so the idea I mean judges
are paid a very good salary and the idea
that they shouldn't have to work some
weekends that you couldn't you know
include them in the mix of of like
having rotating Duty it I find that
offensive it's just because they're
doing it anyway and there's no reason
that they that they shouldn't do it they
do it in other states in some states
they have night courts and stuff I'm not
suggesting that necessarily but there's
there's just no reason that judges
shouldn't have to work uh you know some
some weekends and so I guess I would say
I think you ought to figure that in the
mix of what whatever you're doing that
it's not you know it's not offensive to
me in any way that judges should have to
work weekends because as I said they're
doing it anyway I have no doubt about
that represent mire so if we were to ask
them to do bailed decisions over the
weekend right um number one do they need
ancillary people their clerk the other
people together with them at the same
time and number two roughly how much
time would you think average bail case
takes I think Pro I mean particularly if
you're going to have I assume as you did
I think that Mo that virtually all of
these would be done you know
electronically through Zoom or something
like that um nonetheless I think there
probably would still need to be some
ancillary people they also prob
presumably could be done by Zoom all you
know also but you would probably need
some ancillary support people uh uh to
be doing that and in terms of you know
how uh for initial appearance bail kind
of thing I think uh you said a half an
hour I think that's probably a good
estimate some in some in some matters
you know it that's probably it would
take significantly less than that there
might be a few where it would be more
but I I would say you know the idea of a
half an hour is probably a reasonable
estimate would be my
view I'm I'm sorry I I mean this is a
lot to learn for us are are Judges doing
some bail work now over the weekends do
you know okay I'm seeing no I don't
think so no I don't think they are so
when I saying you know as I said again
as I said the work that I that I think
most judges are doing now on the
weekends is writing orders doing
research that kind of thing most of that
is probably from home but I you know I
think sometime they are going into the
to the local court because it's got a
better Library situation or something
like that but but the idea that they're
not working is just it's not accurate
they
are
yes
Aaron thank you Mr chairman I I did just
want to mention that we did have an
opportunity the judicial branch to speak
with the uh policy committee about the
alternative of of Judges doing these
determinations on weekends and and there
are some complications uh the need for
support staff which is typically
unionized and has a no weekend clause in
their um in their contracts uh the need
for a Judicial decision rather than a
magistrate or bail commissioner decision
to be immediately reported to the
registry which means the registry has to
be open through the weekend rais the
costs and I think the policy committee
came to the realization that the
magistrate saved a lot of those
ancillary Staffing costs they would work
like a bail commissioner does now sort
of a super bail commissioner a highly
qualified bail commissioner and it those
additional costs wouldn't be incurred uh
I completely agree with chairman Lynn
that judges work a lot of hours and they
are certainly working weekends right now
um we we have 44 Circuit Court judges
and our latest evaluation of how many we
need was 65 um so they are they are
working um but judicial time is not
unlimited um and magistrates time is
time are there any more questions I
don't see the commissioner of doit yet
so maybe this would be a good time for
you to
explain some of your amendments I have
sent a text to commission uh chairman
Roy to get his input on the
number maybe we can just oh oh sorry
yeah commissioner goule is at Governor
counsil this morning and he asked if two
o'clock would be
yeah well we'll talk I'll tell them
we'll follow up later all right all
right so why don't we
um how about this we'll just move that
we have five magistrates why don't why
don't we do
that I would rather wait until we talk
to uh chairman Roy you know he was
adamant to on numbers I think he said
there was some flexibility but I don't
know whether
five would meet uh the criminal justice
committee's recommendation and as you
recall the criminal justice committee
committee voted
unanimously uh these bills to bring that
number of magistrates forward so it's a
courtesy to uh chairman Roy I'd like to
hear from him first if that's all right
yeah I don't I mean these are all the
other you know line by line type stuff
is to make everything consistent right
right it's
not you know it it's not
um these are the main decisions I don't
I don't think there's any other cost
item that that aren't up there I have
one question for um represent on the
monitoring by the court is that that was
something you said was right okay so why
don't we talk about that yeah that's a
good point that that is the other big
cost thing so um monitoring so I believe
in these bills you've got an amendment
on monitoring right yeah I think we do
actually this is with the electronic
bracelets is this yeah the the ankle
bracelets yeah
so um as we understand it some counties
and I know marac does and straford does
have uh already they're using these
ankle bracelets on serious um serious
offenders who who are out on bail and
um and
so there's a cost to that they they all
these none of these are owned by the
counties they're all rented and so
there's a there's an ongoing cost for
renting but then there's also monitoring
because there's somebody who's got you
know their cell phone beeps anytime
somebody steps inside the the the
prohibited Zone which according to the
person I talk to happens all the time
right so um and so there and and it
turns out the way this software works is
that the ankle bracelet has effectively
a walkietalkie in it and so the person
monitoring when they get the beep they
can go into the software and say to the
guy hey you're in a restricted Zone get
out of there what are you doing you know
and the guy can answer back and all this
sort of stuff I mean it's you know crazy
and and um charge for a second okay sure
so so uh do do you see what I mean so so
the ankle bracelet talks to them and
they say oh I didn't realize and they
leave whatever so
um and and then the person monitoring if
the person person stays inside this
restricted Zone they call the cops and
the cops come and get the guy so um so
anyways but all that stuff is done by
counties but I the way the bills read
it's done by the courts right so the
courts would have to set up a whole new
system and all that sort of stuff and
they're not in general in charge of
prisoners right they're they're in
charge of um what happens in court so so
number one I would move all this stuff
from the courts to the counties and then
I would simply put in it doesn't seem to
be a cost item because uh except in this
in the case of um of uh people who can't
afford it right there's there's language
in these bills about if somebody is
Indigent and can't afford the $100 a
week or whatever it is then it'll be
covered by the state right so uh um or
the Judiciary so effectively the state
so so um I don't know if we can
estimate what that's cost is going to be
but but it seems like it's a good idea
yeah yeah one of one of the the
questions I have is my understanding is
that the state does this when they do
early early release from the state
prison a lot of times they will have
them on ankle monitors I'm sure we could
find out from the state prison what it's
costing them to do it and if they've
already got a system set up at the state
level
why would we have to create a new system
to you know the court system to do this
if the state is already monitoring and
if they've already got the provisions
for monitoring um you know if it's if
it's established we should use what's
there well we're talking about here I
think pre-trial people right Andor right
but but the state is not normally
involved in the pre-trial phase of it
right they're either in the county jail
or or not right or or in the county
courts right so yeah um anyways go ahead
yeah so just again being respectful of
the process that this has been through
and the negotiated points I guess I
pretty much believe that practically
everything in here is in here for a
reason so before I would interpose our
judgment on it I would ask why it would
set up this
way so I don't know who can answer that
question Miss Gan and uh rep use if you
wanted to speak as well but I I believe
this was relatively late edition that it
was assigned to the courts um so I don't
understand that to be an essential
feature that it be the courts rather
than the counties conducting the
monitoring but but we do not conduct
monitoring now I know in many states
there's a pre-trial division in the
courts and folks that might have worked
in other states uh are familiar with it
we simply don't have that we don't have
any staff that covers monitoring um so I
understand why someone who might have
been in mass or place that there's a
pre-trial would be very familiar with
that and would think that that's an
intuitive place for it um but I I think
the counties administer that here and
prerogative that is my understanding as
well uh so I'm I I don't think that
there was I think part of the reason why
the courts may have been in there in the
first place is because uh we've been
very focused all along in this process
uh in terms of what changing the process
would actually uh mean for the courts in
terms of additional cost in terms of
things like additional person El
requirements um so essentially if we're
getting to the same
outcome I think that's I think that's
workable and the outcome we're trying to
get to by the way is to make sure uh
with all of these bills I think one of
the things that we're trying to achieve
is and and what this compromise is
really all about is enhancing Public
Safety uh and I think that's that's
really um what kept us focus in in
criminal justice and one of the things
we also knew was we had a bunch of
things that we needed to balance uh we
needed to balance the civil rights of
defendants um we needed to uh you know
to balance the fact that we couldn't
make every single change to the system
that we wanted so I think the where we
are on on the bills that have come to
you uh is that I
think in criminal justice I think all of
us view uh these bills and these
processes as a as a good start and I
think one of the things that we found
with B form as a whole is that the
process is evolutionary so I don't think
we're done yet um I don't I'm not sure
we'll ever be done I think there are
always ways we can continue to improve
it but where we are now is we we're in
this unique situation where we have law
enforcement State reps uh on both sides
uh the American civil liberties Union uh
and uh uh every stakeholder you can
imagine um is supporting the compromise
in front of you and I and I think as
representative yel has said um when you
start picking at
threads that's the easiest way to kind
of unwind uh the whole thing because so
many of these things are are so
interrelated to we found that to Pro to
solve one problem we had to address
another problem and sometimes to address
that under Ling problem there were two
more problems that we needed to to do
and that's what made this so involved
and and made it so complicated and you
know I apologize that it came to you in
the form of so many bills um but um
that's what it took to to get it through
and and I really appreciate your work in
trying to move this
forward and we're trying to get to a
home base here representative evil okay
so I just uh as we go down this uh
monitoring issue I just want to be
crystal clear that whether it's the
courts or we come up with another
concept for the counties it's okay from
a policy standpoint that you guys don't
think it is a thread that's going to
make everything ra unravel I think the
most important thing is it gets done uh
uh who does it and who's in charge of
it
yeah so I did speak to Chairman Roy and
uh on the magistrate issue
and he said doesn't really like the idea
but 10 would be better than five or none
but he said 10 would be his preferred
number one for each
County representative
wer we forget we say one per County the
relative sizes of populations to the 10
counties I like his idea better five the
same as each executive counsel because
each one has the same population roughly
so they should have the same exposure to
bad guys on a per capita basis whereas
in counties you got two counties that
have over half the
population so you know it it kind of
makes it awkward when this county has
300,000 people this one has
30,000 you pay the same but your
exposure is much different how many
people are likely to be needing bail so
I think that's that's a good way to look
at it if you want equal populations
obviously district one is going to have
a lot more driving time if someone had
to drive but you know the the
uh by looking at the population I think
we have a strong argument to say this is
equal exposure for each magistrate to
how many what's the percentage of bad
guys per population and I don't think it
varies much from County to
County well there's probably more bad
guys than Kingston than there are in my
town but in all seriousness I think
allow them they send them to the
legislature
[Laughter]
yeah but I I just think again you know
if you look at the executive council
districts as you mentioned district one
up is huge yeah and uh I don't think the
magistrates are going to be restricted
to the counties if you need it the court
needs to have two magistrates that they
Hillsboro County due to you know the
workload in Manchester and Nashville
there's two courts as you know in
Hillsboro County they can be moved
around even though the specific 10
counties they're not going to be
restricted to Sullivan County or
Rockingham County yeah but you know if
you're trying to look at the exposure of
a magistrate likely to have a call The
Districts would be about equal but if
you start to go to counties one little
County with 25,000 people you know they
might not have two a
weekend want to add that my idea kind of
works with the fact that Hillsboro has
two courts nashwa and Manchester are in
separate executive counc
districts so you could have a magistrate
stationed in each area there with the
with the understanding that they are
going to use
telecommunications to address most of
their workload and very rarely will be
in person in front of somebody uh which
is that's the the bail Commissioners
will be traveling to be in person in
front of people the magistrates can be
in an office or a courtroom uh depending
on how the judicial branch lines it up
and do their jobs from the computer to
to have their hearings within those 24
hours so I I I'm I'm in support of five
and obviously the conversations will
continue we know what happens in this
division goes through the full finance
committee and then to the floor of the
house where who knows what happens but I
think out of this Division I would
support five
magistrates so I'm taking that you're
moving that I would I would move we
reduce the number of magistrates from 15
to five and representative Campell is
seconding that further discussion
represent Maguire so I just want to
point out to everybody here there's a
reason why the finance committee is
involved in this process and that is
that um people in the subject area
certainly have their focus but that's
all their focus and we are in charge of
the limited resources of the state and
and we have constraints on us that are
not just however important Judiciary and
law enforcement and all those things are
there's also education there's also
Health there's also Dees there's also
this that and the other you know
Secretary of State everything else and
so we are not made of money you know and
we have to make sure that um when we
spend we're spending wisely it's it's
that simple and and
just because chairman Roy or anyone else
says it's got to be this way well it's
not that way now so so whatever you know
if we can give you halfway to what you
want that's that's some improvement you
sometimes
questiones it's not so much a question
is you know I'm I've always I I thought
the failure in the previous system was
that the bill Commissioners just weren't
trained and if the bail Commissioners
were trained that we wouldn't have the
problems that we're having in the system
and but I've come around a little bit on
supporting the magistrates because of I
think the court systems are overburdened
and this may be a way to help uh help
some of the burden that they have uh and
also take some of the burden off on bail
Commissioners who you know for whatever
reason and again I think one of the
biggest problems is they were not
trained and if they were given training
I think they could do their job
adequately I'm to support A reduced
number of magistrates and you know you
talk about meeting them halfway that
would be seven so would be closer than
halfway than five but um I may vote for
the five I'm still really thinking of it
because I think we can work with a
reduced number of magistrates because I
think the bail Commissioners once they
receive training will be able to do more
adequately yeah I'm so um Can somebody
remind me um what the cost is for the
magistrates and what the difference
between five mostly I want to know what
the difference between five and 10 is
Melissa Mr Hoffman based on the fiscal
note 15 and dividing it's
156,000 per
magistrate and five would cost you
$781,000
so it's
1.4 and then you'd double that for 10
arithmetic could you do the arithmetic
and 10 would be double that just under
1.5 million or just yeah just under 1.5
million so it's 780 versus
1.5
right yes I
mean this is the public safe so this is
I mean I really think this is the place
we should be looking but I'm so like
respectful of all the work that has been
done by the policy committees and chair
Roy in particular I feel like we're
interposing our opinion on how to best
make this system work and support Public
Safety and I would go along with 10 I
cut yeah overall yeah you're right
representative Sweeney do you have any
further suggestions on your five or no I
I would just say I think with firm on
five I'm firm on five I think with the
case load that's presented for these
magistrates under the bail system
they're looking at five to six cases a
week on bail uh that frees up they still
have time to work on other projects and
other cases for the judicial branch as
the judicial branch sees fit it's a they
may use them it's not a sh you know they
use them as they see fit um so I think
five is a good place to start at again
we could be back here a year from now or
two years from now and they say we need
10 we need seven and we can build up
from that five once you have a position
you don't skip we don't scale it back so
five is I think the place to start from
um and five is bigger than zero so
infinitely infinitely representative
Griffin well I I I think I've already
Express and I'm not real supportive of
the uh magistrates but I think five is a
reasonable
compromise okay when the clerk is ready
please call the role okay on this
Sweeney amendment to reduce the number
from 15 to five magistrates seconded by
representative cambrell so I'm just
trying to figure out we don't I don't
have an amendment number no we just if
this passes an amendment with a number
the while she's writing out the motion
I've been certainly torn we are creating
a a new system we're going to try to
make it better I think the work that was
done by the criminal justice committee
and the house Judiciary Committee was
very
commendable um if we went with some of
the options we've discussed today no
magistrates I think that would be a huge
step backwards so I I'm very torn but I
think I will support the reduction down
to five because it gets us started so at
least it gets us started could I ask um
Melissa Mr Hoffman can you just tell me
I think it would be best if we
identified uh the bill number and the
line and the
page I think it's Senate Bill 252 right
for the
magistrates and 240 it's a little bit
confusing 249 establishes the
magistrates um subject to appropriation
which is in the other bill and the
appropriation is in the other bill so I
believe on the first page of this we can
amend 15 down
to five then figure and elsewhere I'll
do the same thing and these will all
eventually be drafted as an amendment to
House Bill
so okay um representative Maguire yes
representative
Griffin yes representative swe
yes representative cambrell yes chair
Wier left okay clerk votes no uh
Representative walner no representative
grassie yes okay the motion carries and
leean has already
yes
yes okay one two three four five six to
two the motion passes
okay all right do we want to take a
little break from this 318 and go to the
next bill since we probably it's really
quick I think they're here they're all
here yeah waiting for us and I I just
[Music]
amendment I think the sponsors
are um Melissa do you have a Amendment
so we are now going to House Bill 5 1577
you so as soon as
represent representative Maguire as soon
as Melissa's finished handing things up
okay so um as you you may recall this is
the bill that said for the new Mach new
voting machines that have uh that do
scans of of the ballots and store those
scans on internal memory cards the uh
the bill was to
um allow those scans to be seen by the
public and so the way the bill was
originally written is that is that the
secretary of state would have an
employee to to um arrange viewings of
these of these scans and so the cost of
it was that employee right so there'd be
a there'd be a person and in general
what we found out was the the memory
cards are not stored by the secretary of
state they're stored by the towns and
they belong to the towns and and that
sort of thing so uh what this amendment
does does is uh El essentially
eliminates the cost it it um keeps the
memory cards where they are now which is
with the towns and it allows um it it
requires the towns to sell uh memory
cards for their cost uh to people who
are who are interested so um all of this
viewing and and look at the cards and
all that stuff happens after the
election eltion is already finalized so
it's not about changing election results
or anything like that it's just a a
matter of interest in in viewing the um
uh viewing these images and the other
data on the memory cards so that's what
the bill does other questions for
representative
Maguire I have representative able thank
you how does this answer the concern
expressed by the by Aaron Hennessy
concerning um accessible ballots and the
Privacy issue right so this does not um
address that issue it's um all ballots
are are essentially viewable during
recounts and um all ballots would be
viewable by the original bill so the
original Bill anybody could come in and
say I want to see all the ballots and
and they would they would be viewed so
that question has sort of already been
bill so from my notes I see here that
this original bill came out of the
election law committee without
recommendations so there was obviously
some disagreement there have you talked
to anybody on Election law or the chair
um I've talked to uh representative wood
and obviously the the the sponsor here
and they were both um in favor of this I
anything you're good if you're if you're
okay so but I did not speak to
representative
Barry any further discussion are you
moving your I'm sorry representative eil
all I was going to say is I did review
um some of the background on this it did
come without recommendation um the con
concerns that were expressed during that
discussion and plus when we had the
Secretary of State there don't seem to
be answered to me so I would have I'm G
to have problem with the bill either way
I I think I could uh go ahead and
support representative Maguire's
Amendment
however okay so repres representative
McGuire are you moving your Amendment
yes please 1347 H is it seconded
represent
cells all right when the clerk we'll
just have a show of hands on the
amendment and then we can vote on the
bill as amended everybody in favor of
the
amendment 8
Z and then representative McGuire is
moving 1577 is oh represent cell thank
you Mr chair I just like to make the
comment that since uh representative
Maguire's amendment has removed the the
fiscal
cost then uh then that's our job is to
look at it from a fiscal point of view
yeah so um I I think that that's a great
thing that we remove any fiscal costs
and I would I would move the bill with
the amend I would second the the
movement of the bill with the amendment
he representa camell's moves
1577 as amended by a previous action and
seconded by representative Maguire or
representative Griffin and I saw your
hand over there we'll keep you on with
the mix thank you oh wait you're you're
the seconder yes I wouldn't want to SP
that and when the clerk is ready please
rall
okay all right so we're um voting on
Bill
OA
am represent M yes represent
yeses
no
no okay we have a few minutes
before our 11:30 we like to bounce back
to
discuss B reform representative mire you
have some amendments um around so I
guess we decided on the magistrates
issue right we did so the other two were
the the monitoring and the 1.7 million
which I guess you wanted to delay so the
monitoring by by counties I think we
have an amendment yeah you have an
amendment saw county is picking up the
yeah who would be the person to speak on
behalf of the counties whether they have
a view or not I don't
know
yeah I don't see currently doing it I oh
yeah that's true spoke to my County you
know jail and the Commissioners they
would prefer that we not uh get involved
in the work that they do um you know
it's one of one of the concerns that
they had was that if we were set a cap
on the uh on on the the cost of the
monitors or what we what they charged
the prisoners or the people that were
out on bail for the monitors is that
they could lose money on them and they
basically make enough to cover the cost
uh I know some some counties roll it
into their County cost and so the
taxpayers pick it up but in straford
county in particular the the person on
bail actually pays the um or on that
been paroled actually pays the cost they
uh they don't do it any other way and so
they they don't want any restriction on
that but they've been doing it and they
have it all set up to do it so that's
not a it's not an issue as long as you
don't interfere with
it representative McGuire would you like
to explain your Amendment
please yeah I I think this may be the
first time I've seen it but but what I
asked for was um again just to switch
the the monitoring function from from
these um the courts to the counties um
and and um essentially require them to
do what some of the counties are are
already doing um I I think we want to
retain the the bus business of if if
people are
Indigent
um and and maybe we would have to pick
up we the state would have to pick up
that cost rather than uh the county
picking up the cost and I I doubt that's
written I see on the second page it says
the court May reimburse yeah right at
the top it says a court May re May order
reimbursement of the cost of monitor to
the county in cour ordance with the
provisions okay so I think that that's
but it would be the court that would
make that decision right well the court
is effectively the state
so that works Erin would you have
question uh I would just like to uh
really commend representative McGuire
you did so much work and research with
uh so many parties and I think that this
is a very useful um addition to the
package that will really help delate
some of the responsibilities that some
of the parts of the Criminal Justice
System have so I just appreciate all of
that groundw work and I think that this
helpful president
Griffin I'd like to ask
um I I see a problem here depending upon
the effective
date because uh you require ing a 24hour
review and uh we we don't have the
magistrates in place so what when would
effective well let's get out the how it
Senate Bill
252 although again we're we're planning
to to rewrite this as as House Bill 318
and it'll have an effective dat section
then presumably if there was an issue
there this section could be effective
January 1st 2025 yeah that's when
effective but yeah if you want to if you
want to put in into the final bill that
the magistrates can be hired
immediately and and these kind of
sections take place January 1st I think
that to be yeah okay that makes sense
I'm not suggesting
immediately I'm just suggesting that you
be careful well I mean the part about
hiring magistrates could be on passage
right and
so you know and the same thing with
coordinator Mr
Hoffman I I expect that after the
committee goes through all all three
bills then
um you would revisit all the effective
dates um to make sure that everything
aligns so maybe after all the amendments
are approved and adopted and we can go
back and look at the effective dates
consider are you okay with that yeah
represent Sweeny shman I saw Kate Horgan
from the County Association came in I
don't know if we want to bring her up
speed on how this impacts the counties
sorry to put you on the spot
K so thank you if you could just
identify yourself because we're just
about ready to pass on all these costs
[Laughter]
for thank you representative bman and
members of the committee and thank you
to representive Sweeney for giving me a
a text message I sprinted over from the
state house so I apologize for being a
little out of breath um I did talk to
representative McGuire about this
amendment yesterday we would draw your
attention to page two lines 9 through
18 the way I am reading this it would
cause an administrative nightmare for
the association of counties and county
government um so it says if a court
finds a person is Indigent for repaying
the is not Indigent the court will order
shall order them to reimburse the county
for the payment unless that
person's case terminates without a
conviction for any
offense that means unless someone is
found guilty you we can't be reimbursed
for anything regards to electronic
monitoring not specifically just the
electronic monitoring that is posted
previously in this bill and the amount
of work that it would take to try and
find these people to get that
reimbursement after they are released we
never getting paid back for anything and
this language we believe would be an
unfunded mandate on the counties
okay so I will respond to that so um I
think in general and maybe um Judge Lynn
would like
to agree or not agree but in general we
[Music]
um it's okay to charge people who are
accused um when they're not Indigent
right so so in the sense that they pay
for their attorney they pay for all
kinds of costs right so so this
particular line maybe could simply be
struck I mean this this unless so on
right because because
essentially
um there's there's no sort of legal
reason that that everybody has to be
made whole on all their costs when
they're accused of a crime go through
the whole process um that that would
certainly make us happier okay and I
think um it would uh you would probably
to cross out the next line too that
include could we get your name again
please for the record Kate Horan h o r g
an and what I will suggest is you and
representative Maguire get together and
work out some language that will satisfy
the County's concerns I would be happy
to thank you thank
you miss all right we're almost to 11
almost to 11:30 so we can bounce the
next one you're okay with getting
that veterans court I think we have an
amendment for that so next on our agenda
is House Bill 1589 stablishing a
veterans treatment Court representative
Maguire you have an amendment
I so we're going to name you Mr
Amendment that's fine with me so um
like's cutting trees down yeah
all right anyways um if you remember
this bill it just had a straight uh $2
million a year cost uh for veterans
court in the and the way it it divided
that cost was just straight C payments
to
counties um to implement the veterans
court and it was it was so much to
Hillsboro County and so much to
Rockingham County and so on down the
list and
um so whereas the numbers we were
hearing about the number of cases were
were you know kind of in the low double
digits or something you know annually I
mean it it
wasn't like a lot of cases and so $2
million every year for you know what
sounded like 40 or 50 cases was was too
much so um what we talked about and
what's in this amendment is to instead
have the payments to the counties be
$5,000 a case up to the number that was
originally in the bill right so so my
estimate I think our estimate was that
this would reduce the 2 million to maybe
more like
300,000 it says 245,000 ought to exceed
per year right but I think that's for a
particular County that's size County
there's three different standards for
right so so those are the numbers that
we're in the bill originally right the
245 the 150 and the 100 I think those
were or maybe it was even more than that
question represent grassy what we're
looking at here in this is it said up to
so a county who is a Louge County they
would not be able to get more than
$250,000 to set up their veterans court
and a medium County wouldn't be able to
get more than
$150,000 for setting up their Court a
small County wouldn't be able to get
more than a 100,000 I'd like to see
Which counties those were um to you know
who fits into what what's considered a
large what's considered a medium County
if we could get that breakdown it on
line 20 oh okay I'm sorry I was looking
side
okay and I think those are unchanged so
in other words my County would get 250
could could get up to $250,000
$245,000 for setting up their Court
thank you
have you had a chance to discuss this
with our friends at the National
Guard National
Guard uh
no no but they were here he's here now
so I thought maybe we could
okay I mean he's the one of the source
numbers so for the record Warren Perry
Deputy agent General New Hampshire's
Department of military Affairs and
veteran services so again I can't get to
the cost or how the costing would work I
mean I'm not I'm not an expert in the
court system or court costs I can really
just reiterate what we believe the
demand would be on this veteran court
system and you know based on numbers
that we were able to glean from the past
we think you know the big the best
estimate we have is about 27 a year
across the state and then we inflated
those numbers a little bit to up to
about 40 so that we would just make sure
we covered the cost of what's going on
but still not a tremend mendous Demand
on the system right so that's that's
kind of you mean that's that's where I'm
at uh so with regard to the amendment I
I don't think I could comment directly
on the impact of cost I think that's
something that the judicial system and
Department of Corrections would be
better suited to talk about in terms of
cost I apologize for just not being an
expert in the money piece no problem are
there any
questions singan thanks for being
here all right the division's pleasure
with
1277 representative grassy oh I'm sorry
first with Aaron about this the only
question I have
is
um it's not clear to me how in other
words if a if a county wants to apply
for a
grant um it's not
they may not know how many cases they're
going to have in the in applying so I'm
that's my guess I I guess I'm just
wondering about the the mechanics of
this how What You Know The Envision
envisioning how this is going to work if
the if Hillsboro County is going to
apply for a grant um you know how how
are they going to know what they're uh
should should there be some language
that says they may you know this will be
based on the prior year
or uh you know that that's my only
concern yeah I would agree with this and
and um basically this language is
unchanged from the bill when it was a
grant but I think it should be more of a
you know reimburse the
counties annually or quarterly or
whatever is to a Max up to this maximum
per year you know something like that so
we we can work on changing that that
would be that would be that would make
perfect sense to do that and can I can I
just ask one other question just to make
sure the the section the the first Roman
numeral one the the first amend RSA 490
colon
i-11 that first paragraph of the
amendment is that is that just is that a
change or is that just it seemed like it
was very close if to the original Bill
and I'm just wondering if there was
actually any change at all this is this
is a sh to
May um so if you remember oh
oh no I'm sorry I that that's fine I was
it is a CH that's that is airly
significant change right so we're
allowing
um we're allowing counties to implement
veterans courts not forcing them to Sor
and and we're um we're giving them a
little carrot which is the
$5,000 right so that's the no that makes
sense good I have no problem with that I
think I recall you being in here and
discussing the sh May issue on this well
you know what I was thinking of the Shel
May issue on the training the judge's
training that's what I was yeah that's
what I was I know you don't like shell
no no no no no I do I actually do like
shell I I think it's uh it's some other
people maybe I was just kidding
represented grassy yeah looking at this
and if and particularly if we put it in
as a reimbursement I think would
probably be a better way to go but the
thing is is that based on the size of
the counties that you have here this
could cost us up to $3 million just shy
of 3 million it's
2.95 so if everybody maxed out their
reimbursements so represent Willer
numbers yeah representative Maguire will
get together with the general lady from
the county that was behind Mr Hoffman
sure try to work this out yeah we can do
it yeah all right thanks
all right so we'll have an
amendment on this with that correction
Monday we're gonna meet Monday okay good
you like meeting Monday works for me is
Monday okay with everybody or Tuesday is
that the day after
I we haven't made it official yet but
we're gonna have to meet I'm sure got
button these things up representing
cambrell so you'll okay for a Monday or
would you rather have it
Tuesday
oh come
on 10 o' 10 10 o'clock on Tuesday then
close
yous no actually represent
W so do we want to go back and discuss
any more on 318 represent McGuire
because you do have another amendment
right um 318 or 249 or
delay we haven't done
105 were just Bas that yeah so 105 well
we're going to merge it into 318 I think
the other we yes I think I think there
is one so represent Maguire has an
amendment on 1
005 we'll pass out since we have a
here you stay pretty
busy I'm burning the candle at both ends
burned
on all right he representative Maguire
has an amendment
1113 on
10:05 all right so some of this um there
may be people objecting but the main the
main
thing this was in response to um what we
heard from the
Judiciary about
um how effective this would be right we
heard that they wanted a Judicial
training coordinator but that the
details they wanted left up to them so
so this one cut out the original Bill
had a significant you know prescriptive
inspection said you know this kind of
trains so and so this cuts out except
for new judges those kind of
restriction and the other thing it also
does is it it has the training
train so that um bail Commissioners are
adequately trained and it keeps the
original remember we had talked about
moving this to the end of the the next
days
all representative Lynn I see this came
out of your committee like uh 18 to one
are you any comments on the amendment or
Amendment so this bill was actually
based on a lot of testimony that we
received uh sorry for the record
representative Caitlyn cab um on a lot
of testimony we received in the special
committee for the family court and I
think it really is important to leave
the number of hours in here because they
already were supposed to doing it by
Court rule and it's just been on the
back burner because it's not required I
think it's really important that we do
require a number of hours we had lots of
testimony regarding this it was
basically the priority bill that came
out of that committee so um I really do
do think that it's important that we put
that back in and um I'll let
representative Lynn speak to it but he
didn't see anything wrong with saying
shell do this specific number of hours
and so that was why the committee had
changed from May to
Shell so you like the amendment I don't
like this no I don't like the amendment
because it's taking out the number of
hours sorry I why I want to make it
clear I'm fine with putting in like it's
interesting because with the bail
Commissioners were prescribing a certain
number of hours but then with our judges
we're not I mean we our judges should be
more trained than our bail
Commissioners but I'll let judge
representative Maguire I think has a
question for you thank yes thanks for
coming
um one thing that you didn't have with
the hours is the concept that a new
judge needs more hours of training than
somebody who's been in 10 years 20 years
something like that do you because it
had a flat number for every judge for
every year does that still make sense to
you or or not so it it it did have a
difference because it did state that it
in the beginning like you'd complete an
orientation and then after that it was a
certain number of hours per year
and if
you think of it in the context of I
mean the number of hours that were in
there was 16 hours or something like
that I don't really think it's that much
when you consider that a doctor does a
100 hours you know every two years I
mean I just I think our judges should be
as educated as as other professions they
don't have to do the number a certain
number of hours as required by the bar
anymore when they're judges either so
um I think it's just important that
there so the number of hours on there
was 24 hours um for judges and it
was 16 hours for the superior court
clerks and uh 12 hours for the circuit
court
clerks and the number of hours for the
orientation wasn't specific in here it
just said that they had to complete it
within 3 months but then after that was
like kind of the continuing education
requirement in there it's not changing
the impact of the fiscal Noe or not
because it's still providing the
training coordinator and what we are
told with the training coordinator is is
well they can kind of a lot of times
arrange to bring somebody in or or you
know to conduct these trainings rather
than send people off to conferences and
whatnot that might cost a lot more money
but I still think that it is important
that the whole purpose is to make sure
that our our judges are trained and not
just to put it on the back burner so I
don't think it makes sense to give them
the money for the training coordinator
position but then not actually require
that they do the training I mean that
completely def defeats the purpose of
the bill okay I don't I don't have a
strong objection so I we could put those
things back in that's
you yes representative Lynn the only the
only thing I want to say and I um here
is that uh apparently there had been
some suggestion that um to have the more
detailed thing in somehow violated
separation of powers um respect I don't
I'm not sure who said that but I
remember you know for I I have the
greatest respect for you all may
remember hoe zibble uh who used to be
our uh legal counsel um frequently he
would come over here and make that kind
of an argument and with great respect
for Howie who I I I love dearly
um it's baloney it has no it had stop
and think about this the argument always
was you can't tell another branch of
government um uh how to how to do this
and whenever that argument is made you
have to ask yourself well if we can't
tell another branch of government to do
this we the legislature okay let's
assume that's true then that means you
can't tell the executive branch to do
this either but as representative she
didn't really reference this in her in
in what she just said but U if you look
in the executive and the laws we have
dealing with the executive branch we
tell them what kind of training and all
all kinds of things we say you have to
have you know somebody to fill this
position has to have this kind of
training or this kind of there's no
there's no Prov no problem at all with
doing that um it doesn't in any way
interfere with the judiciary's
independent Independence in terms of
making decisions it doesn't tell them in
any way this is how you should decide
this case or that it's has nothing to do
with that it's just um it's just saying
judges have to have certain training and
uh you know that I don't see any problem
at all with that and I think for the
reasons that uh representative couta
pointed out it it does seem like it
makes sense to say um you know
particularly given that you're going to
have the training coordinator it does
really make sense to say this these are
the kind kind of things that the
training should deal with and I I so I I
I strongly support that
idea so um what I think people making
that argument would say is well in the
case of the courts we have in the
Constitution part two article
73a which says the the Chief Justice
shall be the administrative head of all
the courts he shall make rules governing
administration of all courts and
practice and procedure followed in all
courts and these rules shall have the
force and effec of law right so um does
that no do I don't think there's
something equivalent for the governor
for example with regard to his powers
you see I mean with regard I'm sorry my
recollection is that was added after
what was voted on as a constitutional
amendment they the such things shall
have the power of law was not in what
was approved by the voters I see
somebody just decided to add it and it
was illegal that's what my friend
U would tell me all the time Bill
Gardner what's that I is it up to Bill
Gardner maybe anyway I know I I I I
think the short answer is that does not
I I that does not in fact there was a
this was the subject of a long long
debate of you know 20 20 years ago or so
um and and in fact the the Supreme Court
actually wrote a decision subsequent to
that debate basically saying that the
legislature has the power to make uh to
to affect sort of Court procedure as
long as it doesn't interfere with the
essential adjudicatory functions of the
Court this kind of thing does not and so
it's uh um that
that's it was Mar told me
that added the language later
um so are you clear representative
Maguire what needs to be done yeah I
think so so Mike will we'll put back in
a this is uh going to be my third time
putting myself at Peril disagreeing with
not only a former Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court but the chair of the house
Judiciary Committee and a very very good
lawyer um I with one of the things that
I did and take before I took this job I
read an extensive Corpus of law on
article
73a and his influence is throughout that
body of law a very influential Bar
review article he wrote cases that he
adjudicated I completely understand his
perspective um but the but the body of
law that
has co-existing Authority between the
legislature and the judicial branch is
the Rules of Evidence it is the rules of
procedure it is not the internal
administration of the court system that
is a separate Clause of 73a and it is
what most people understand as the
independence of the Judiciary the idea
that there is something different about
the Judiciary and that it is still the
standing law on the books in the state
of New Hampshire that the uh legislature
can't determine the discipline of the
judicial branch uh I don't know how it
could be the law that the legislature
can't determine internal discipline but
they can determine training those are
essentially two halves of the same
administrative Personnel uh
Administration that are to the heart of
what it means to administer the
Judiciary I'm not saying this in any way
to challenge the power of the
legislature over the Judiciary which is
vast the legislature can abolish a court
it can create new judgeships it can
raise the it create new causes of action
it could lower the maximum punishment
for murder to a year the power that the
legislature has is very very vast the
narrow area of self Administration and
Independence is so small small and there
is a lot of danger I know that the bill
that um rep Lyn and rep cutab worked on
who are both excellent legislators who
coordinate very closely with the
legislature and do things that are
extremely helpful to the branch um and
this this argument that there should be
a Judicial training coordinator is
perceptive it's not an idea that we came
up with it's an idea that rep kutab came
up with and I think it's a very very
smart idea um but the danger that's not
in this bill but is contained in the
idea that the legislature can regulate
this area is that you can overcome
something that's not in the law by
forcing judges to be trained in it force
them with a presumption that a case
should be decided a certain way um that
that's not here but that's why training
is not closely regulated by another
branch of government the Judiciary has
to be independent in its determination
of cases based on the law um so I I
appreciate the idea to have a Judicial
training coordinator which as I said is
excellent um the advice that I
originally gave rep kutab was to Simply
take her recommendations and change her
shs to maze because the Judiciary will
listen with respect when the legislature
speaks when they say we it is our
suggestion to you that you have this
number of hours or these topics we will
listen with respect whether that is
verbal whether that is in a hearing
whether it is in a statute but if it is
a shall then the statute is I believe
unconstitutional um so I would I would
ask that the advice be given from the
legislature in a form that is
constitutional this is something that is
you know as you say it's been maintained
from the times of how he's it appears in
numerous other laws for example our
training of our court security officers
we can certify them under executive
standards if the Supreme Court uh chief
justice allows so we language like this
appears in many other bills and laws in
order to ensure that they are
constitutional if it's not
constitutional it may be collaterally
attacked in litigation the person who's
being required to do the training can
say that the law is unconstitutional and
that they're not required to do it and
they'd very likely be victorious if it
is in May and the Chief Justice
implements it his independent action is
constitutional and protects the
requirement uh so I I understand the
arguments that are being made and I just
and I disagree at my Peril but I I
simply have to maintain this argument I
think it is very important that the
Judiciary has this narrow area of self-
administration so that we can maintain
our independence but that is not in any
way a suggestion that we would not
follow the recommendations that we
received in a we would listen with
so I see the word shell all throughout
this amendment and that's got got you on
your head I guess I and I I I think what
um what is in the original bill was Mays
it was converted in committee to shells
and it was an 181 vote because I
persuaded only one person when I argued
with uh representative Lynn I we went
181 he had 18 I had one I think was how
that argument went um and it was changed
to sha and I see that there are shs in
this Amendment but they have as directed
by the Chief Justice which is another
way that you can preserve the
constitutionality of the bill because it
creates the possibility of a waiver or
an adjustment based on administrative
circumstances so as I read the amendment
now and I and I believe you adopted the
first page of this amendment in a
previous meeting that you had on this
bill I believe that we can Implement
that constitutionally um I I don't take
a position on whether you add the bail
educational requirements to the
amendment but the amendment now I
believe is constitutional but so also
would be an amendment which takes rep
kab's original Bill and converts her shs
to
ma it certainly doesn't seem like it's a
terribly onerous one hour of training to
look at ethics and other things you know
we have we absolutely have the ability
to implement this I think I mentioned
when I last spoke on it we we well
exceed these requirements I I believe
representative kutab does a great deal
of research um in in the bills that she
proposes and spoke to us about our
existing training requirements so her
suggestions I had understood Were Meant
to uh Implement some of the things that
we already do uh you know our hours
requirements are typically much higher
and these are all topics that we
currently
cover further questions for Aaron seeing
none the uh division would like to act
on the amendment or you all we all
representative Griffin I'd like to point
out that we uh we just voted an
amendment to uh create the
magistrates and I don't see the word
magistrate in here anywhere shouldn't
they be getting the same training as a
bail
commissioner
yeah um so
um I don't know if there they're
considered a court staff or or not I
113 judges comma magistrates comma bail
Commissioners comma administrators comma
staff all right we'll get a corrected
Amendment shortly now I'm unclear on
whether or not you be changing any of
these shells to maze or should we vote
sure absolutely you're very much
involved with this bill so we'd like to
things uh so the training coordinator
actually wasn't my idea it came from a a
meeting with judge king and and some
other uh staff members but um the so
what she's saying is the initial bill as
it was put in not as amended by the
house which did still say the number of
hours was constitutional like where it's
where it had the shells because it said
under the discretion of the chief
justice so if we could at least put in
the number of hours to make it match
like that original bill and if we don't
want it to say
the the shell as amended in committee
that's fine but if we could at least put
the number of hours back in I do really
that I I guess on on you know we keep
talking about policy issues right this
is is not a financial issue so maybe we
should go along with the bill as the as
the committee passed it I don't know
what do you think well that would be my
suggestion but
yeah I mean but I think why don't we
vote on doing that right all right all
right so so I'll propose that we restore
the bill to the the way that section of
the bill the number of hours and the and
leaving the sh to the the way the
committee passed them is it seconded
representative
wer further discussion on that everybody
clear did it come from the house as a
May or a shall it came as sh as shall
yeah yeah May was only in the original
bill that they then amended to
sh and so
basically if we do the shall then we're
discounting what the general count
just was advising us about yes on the
bill we we are citing with
representative Lynn instead of the
instead of the general Council of the
Jud okay all right I as a all right as a
lawyer I have I struggle with
that all right when the clerk is ready
please call the role on representative
Maguire's Amendment which was seconded
by represent a Wilder okay I thought we
would just have an informal vote on this
particular issue all we can
do yeah you're going to withdraw
everything and go back to the
original no no no because we still want
bail
Commissioners we want magistrates and
Commissioners well we'll we'll we'll
hold off until we clear on what uh
representative McGuire is going to add
to his
language being 12:00 we'll break for
lunch and be back here at 1:00 for
representa Maguire has another amendment
all
e
okay to see US
senator
here so good afternoon we'll resume our
discussion on House Bill
representative Maguire has an amendment
he would like to discuss which the full
finance committee heard yesterday as a
non- gerine
Amendment so representative
Maguire thank you Mr chairman so a big
decision before we get into more detail
is the the overall structure of this
bill and that's why we had that nerain
Amendment hearing yesterday and so the
decision is between the original House
Bill
1633 and this amendment uh
124h and and the main difference in
these two structures is one is what they
call the agency model and the this one
is what they call the franchise model
and so it has to do with sort of who's
in charge and um who's kind of directing
the whole business and that sort of
thing um On's one's akin to a bunch of
diff individual Rec regulated businesses
obviously strongly regulated because of
the of the subject matter but the other
is more akin to um a master business and
a and a bunch of uh um subsidiary
franchises and so um we are told from
the governor and from um our contacts in
the Senate that this is what that they
want the franchise model uh we are also
told they will not vote for the version
that the house passed and we are told
that
um they are either unwilling or
incapable of uh making significant
changes in the Senate so um if we want
to see a bill pass passed and I'm not
sure that everybody does but um for
those of us who do um I think we should
amendment are there questions for
representative
Griffin this amendment is very much like
the agency amendment in many
respects uh and I'm concerned about the
division of
revenues that are in both the bill and
the
amendment if if this amendment were to
pass the committee are you prepared to
offer an amendment to change the uh
distribution of
revenues the answer is yes so regardless
of which one this is this is sort of
deciding a base right and then
regardless of which base we have then we
have a long list of further topics to
talk about which would be true of either
one right so either one all these things
make a difference right so so those will
be individual decisions after
this represent
grassy I we worked on this I'm also on
the Commerce Committee we work tired on
this bill for a number of weeks and you
know I I just have a problem and I know
we've all received a number of emails
about this bill as well and I think that
I need to support what the Commerce
Committee came up with with the work
that we did there and I think that is
the best way to go with the franchise
program instead of going with the agency
U approach that we have here I mean if
the Senate has problems with passing a
bill I don't see why we have to do their
hard work here for them I think they
they need to debate this they need to
make up their mind on a bill and they
need to be send something back to us if
we want to see marijuana you know
cannabis legalization in the state of
New Hampshire
I I I'm I'm supporting the the commer
committee's position on this I don't
think we should be changing the policy
and uh you know let the Senate do what
they
will further questions representative
sweee thank you I I think I understand
where everyone's coming from and it's a
tough part for our committee to be in
because we're not supposed to engage in
the policy but this model that's in
front of us on this amendment is the
most likely to become law model that we
have and I think our responsibility as
the finance committee is to make sure to
protect the state budget to protect the
taxpayers that we are fully vetting the
most likely to become law option ahead
of us so I would urge support of this
amendment I do I I understand there will
be further amendments on how we break
down the finances and where the revenue
goes and potentially where penalties lie
and all the different parts of the the
white board that representative Maguire
has listed there but I do believe we
have a responsibility to the legislature
to fully vet the financial
implementation of the franchise model so
place represent a while or anything to
add well my constituents don't expect me
legalization representative cell thank
you Mr chair well from a I won't look at
it from a policy policy standpoint but
from a strictly Financial standpoint the
amendment before us I believe to be is
is costly and I don't believe it's cost
competitive and I believe it's a losing
proposition from a financial standpoint
from what I see here yes so I would be
against this
amendment further
questions represent sweee thank you Mr
chairman I I will say I think we can
expect an updated fiscal analysis from
The Liquor Commission as early as
compared to what we've received earlier
that showcases that for this budget it's
not as costly as it was once presented
to be and I think if we were to adopt
the amendment we'd be able to get into
that
conversation thank you Mr chairman so
just to address that specifically this
amendment does have a higher um uh fee
or or uh cut for the for the state
compared to the other one one is 10%
this is
125% so in that sense it's more money
for the state um and secondly it has um
the the issue of what's the cost of the
regulation I think is roughly the same
in the two bills it's not the same on
paper yet but but we're going to get to
that issue right here
and so it would be the same you know
they're going to need the same kind of
computer system they're going to need
roughly the same personnel and and all
that sort of thing so um I guess it's
possible that the the franchise model
has more rules so it might be a little
more costly in that sense but I I don't
amount seeing no further questions I do
have a couple of comments first of all I
agree with representative cells and
representative grassy on statements made
by them and also you representative
Sweeney that we need to do
something uh however I don't believe the
Maguire amendment is that something I
think we need to stick with the house
position because if you look at the
Maguire Amendment and I believe this is
pretty much copied from what we were
given by senator abbis in my quick not
number by number but reading it through
yester
an amendment myself that strictly stays
within the um excuse me guidelines of
financial
policy uh for the most part and that's
uh deleting some of the issues that give
broad authority to The Liquor Commission
for transfer of funds that that would
require fiscal committee oversight as is
done with other departments as we all
know in the State uh there's a maybe we
ought to pass that out since I've
excuse
I so even though this looks like a very
extensive Amendment there's only a few
things in there and as Mike explained
that because certain sections were
changed within the proposal the almost a
complete Amendment had to be redrafted
but there's specific areas that I will
Point your attention to uh on page three
for
instance um doing away with the uh
substance use prevention treatment
recovery uh that was a
new commission if you will or fund that
we we spoke about that uh over and above
the governor's Commission of drug and
alcohol
abuse uh it
eliminates all the percentage
contributions in the original Bill found
on page
33 starting with the 65% education trust
fund the 10% for the community
investment fund and so forth going down
uh on page again 33 of the initial
bill
there was broad language in there giving
the Liquor Commission complete authority
to move money without any legislative
oversight that's been
eliminated on page
11 some more important pieces on the I'm
sorry going to page 10 of the top number
line three Roman five would be a
requirement that the commission would
have to send a report report to the
Commerce Commission Commerce Committee
committee on their progress as far as
making all this work and that would be
uh no later than three months after the
effective date of the chapter and
continuing and I don't see the time Mike
quarterly but so I'll mark that I think
the quarterly report got left out yeah
okay quarterly reporting by
the
commission and then one of the more
substantial Financial
changes instead of the money coming from
the general fund whatever money that
would be whether it's $18 million $8
million that would come directly from
funds um so the appropriation of
$100,000 doll is at the bottom of page
11 appropriation uh found at line 24
both of those Appropriations would come
from the liquor fund and not General
Hoffman I think you covered it and the
quarterly is in there at the beginning
of that that section on report okay I
guess so again that's my amendment to
try to stick with the house
position um I did share the amendment I
don't know if representative Le has had
a chance to review my suggestions but uh
it's a prime sponsor I let her know this
morning and what I had proposed so
think I don't think I added anything I
five okay the way this is drafted they
replaced the whole section so you've got
a whole bunch of pages without any
change and that's one of the things that
was just kind of repasted so letters and
numbers changed but content didn't
I I guess representative cells thank you
Mr chair uh just to be clear so if and
when revenues are generated where would
the revenues go once they would come
back to the general just thank
you as you'll see and I think it's uh
remaining funds shall be deposited in
the general funds found in page 11 so
once
again everyone that I think we've heard
from and all the documentation we've
received nobody expects that the state
will receive any revenue from either
plan for up to two
years so there may be a lot of time to
add and Fiddle with this but anyway
these are my suggestions based on what I
heard from folks that support the house
position anyway representative evil yeah
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for the work that you did on your
Amendment um I would be supportive of
your Amendment and not the Maguire
Amendment
um I I I don't know that the Senate
can't make changes that they that might
it seems to me they do what they want to
do um on a bill over there I think it's
really important that we pass a bill
that establishes a house position on
several things that are of great
interest to us many of which that have
been discussed here but in particular a
good pathway or a better pathway for
atcs um and and um other items like that
and as much as you know we would like to
have the opportunity to fully vet the
franchise model I just don't think that
we have that um option at that point and
I guess in going through the policy
analysis and commerce you had both these
options and you chose the licensing
option um that's here um and just again
out of respect for the policy work
that's been done in the house and the
votes that have been taken on the house
floor I think with these few tweaks um
we could be respectful of the process
and also uh lay down sort of a marker on
on our fiscal concerns with the
bill representative grassy I I would
just say that the work that the Commerce
Committee did was basically
herculan effort on the part of
Representative Leon to make the changes
that it were expressed to her were
needed to get the governor and the
Senate on board and and I think she
pushed it as far as she could to the
point where the Cs committee was just
going to say no more we like this bill
as it is um it was a compromise on a lot
of people's Parts there were a lot of
things that the minority of the
committee felt the Democrats on the
committee felt we didn't want to see but
we agreed to do this to get a bill over
the over the Finish in the house this is
The house's position it came through a
lot of struggle and a lot of work and if
we should send that position the policy
position to the Senate and let them work
it out and if they disagree with us and
they want to send a completely different
Bill back to us that's fine but let them
make that decision because I think when
they see our bill and they get our bill
over there and they work through it I
think they may see that we came to a
here
represent Maguire so I I think I
understand the politics that are going
on here
um we all know that this this um
amendment makes this Dead on Arrival
doesn't bother me that much because um
I'm not sort of that thrilled with
either one of these bills but um but
what's going to happen is whatever will
pass the house it'll go to the Senate
and die and it'll the the story on the
headline will be uh Republicans killed
cannabis right and so uh and since since
70% 75% something like that want
cannabis it's a political thing and I
understand
it represent grassing yeah I I I don't
think this is the thing that the
Republicans Republicans and Democrats
worked on this bill hard to get it
so Republicans have as much game in this
bill the house position as Democrats do
so if the Republicans want to kill a
Republican bill
fine I hope we can leave politics out of
it because
I I know I'm I'm like a lot like
representative wer I would be happy to
vote itl because I I think there's
probably a lot more work to be done here
but I do support the work that um the
representative from dery did my
colleague from Rochester serving over in
Commerce and none of us can predict what
the house is going to do let alone try
to predict what the Senate's going to do
so I think the house needs to stand
strong and send something over in
support of the work of the Commerce
Committee and the representative who is
sure I am yeah but uh so and again I I
respect the work that you've done
representative Maguire I know that this
is probably a struggle for you because
the draft that came from the senator
includes a lot of things that you're
completely opposed to and I
certainly understand that so you've
brought up a number of issues here all
of which are on our list to talk about
right all of which can be changed in
this bill right it this this bill is
about a base it's about a starting point
all the other things that you brought up
are are trivial ancillary issues right
that are going to be fixed if and when
we start they're not going to be fixed
in one in one thing let me make the let
me make the
case um it's more than just what the
governor wants or what the senate senate
wants it's a case
for why do we want this compared to that
right I mean why do we want the
franchise model versus that
okay what I think is the ultimate um
benefit for the for the state is the
commission model right I mean we have
the most successful liquor business in
the country all right it it comes with
some cost right it comes with the cost
of the liquor available in New Hampshire
is less varied than it is in other
places we have we have you know big
volumes of fewer items but the the all
profits from
it accw to the state okay um and 50% of
those profits are paid by people who
don't live in New Hampshire so uh if you
look on paper the number of gallons of
alcohol drunk in New Hampshire is twice
the national average and it's not
because we're drunks it's because we're
making money out of people from M who
visit so this is a successful model
because those revenues
displace other taxes we would
necessarily have to have the level of
spending we have right so it allows us
to have lower business taxes lower
property taxes lower um uh all the other
taxes right and this tax is the liquor
tax is
particularly economically uh beneficial
right it's a it's a tax on something
that's a luxury it's a tax on something
that is not a necessity like housing
like gainful employment right those
business taxes and those property taxes
are taxes on Necessities not taxes on
luxuries all of these liquor taxes are
paid 100%
voluntarily as as we can see from people
out of state I see cannabis as in the
same um model cannabis is a luxury it is
not a
necessity even though some use it as a
medication and so on but
it's it's something where at the moment
we we we're on the edge of History here
in the sense that something that's
currently not sold can be sold and we
have to talk about how um and if in the
long run we could have a cannabis
commission similar to a Liquor
Commission we could be in the same
beneficial boat that we are with liquor
right it's not easy it's not guaranteed
but it'd be the only way to do it if we
go with this um agency model we will
have ordinary businesses that sell um
sell cannabis uh they'll be regulated
they'll be taxed a little bit there
won't be any different than things that
happen in other states and so we will be
missing out on those
revenues that displac
important revenues and and revenues that
are less um economically um beneficial
so um that's the reason to go for the
franchise model
because a franchise or can always create
company-owned
stores right we all know that 15 stores
is not going to be the final number all
right the final number is going to be
hundred stores or something in that
ballpark and with the franchise model
the other 85 stores can be New Hampshire
State Stores just like New Hampshire
liquor stores and so they can gain all
those profits and so on that's the
reason for the franchise model so
um you know not only is this not going
to pass in the long run all right but
it's not the right thing in the long run
in my opinion thank you Mr
chairman thanks sir president MCG I do
have one comment though um you said we
could take what the Senate has given us
or the senator has given us and
then adjust this document to fit our
needs right so why would we go to all
that trouble to adjust the Senate
Amendment or your
amendment when you just told us that if
we send the house version over it's dead
at the Senate I'm just because of the
model because of the base because of the
structure that's the difference the
details how much The Liquor Commission
is paid where do the funds go what the
penalties are for smoking on the street
and all those kind of things those are
individual details that can be changed
all the things you mentioned but what
can't be changed is that one is
fundamentally an um regulating
independent businesses it's a it's a
regulatory model it's a licensing model
right and the other is creating a
franchise creating a single business if
you will with uh subparts with with
franchises all right that's different
and so it's it would be hard if not
impossible to
point so just one comment that you
mentioned the penalties now on page
seven of the draft um it talks about
penalties and smoking in public we heard
from the good senator from Salem if that
was it included a misdemeanor charge at
the second offense it was done as far as
he was concerned so I'm just concerned
that we spent a lot of effort trying to
get to a model that you believe we
should send to the Senate and we bypass
the work of the Commerce Committee and
what we've already done I I just can't
get my head around that I'm perfectly
willing to change that section to be
what's in the other bill right I don't
think that this is a it may be as I
understand it it's a significant issue
for one Senator Senator not for all
senators all right so I'm personally
opposed to that section as it sits in
this amendment all right and I'm willing
to to change it to what's in your
Amendment or what's in the original Bill
if there's any differences or what's an
existing really I'm I'm I would like to
see what's an existing law
um so you're right I mean this bill this
amendment that I'm proposing needs lots
of changes well so what I mean you you
have an amendment that makes lots of
changes too right
so okay four it doesn't really matter
right the point is what's the structure
what's the base that we can then move
forward on and we're going to borrow
things from the house bill and add it to
this base but the question this is the
the main question at the moment is where
do you start all right and that's
all and just a reminder to the division
we have to have everything out of here
by Monday of next week so another
concern we spent a lot of time on this
issue and we have an executive session
that the the chair for Tuesday is that
right Mr
afternoon representative grassie yes Mr
chairman I think that you know one of
the things that
Mr representative McGuire had mentioned
that it's the franchise system is easy
to do but I mean we've had information
and testimony before this committee that
if we set up a franchise model here
we're now per under the purview of the
Federal Trade Commission and the federal
franchise regulations so now we bring
the federal government into this if we
go with franchises we now have Federal
interference into what we're doing here
in the State Licensing is much simpler
to do than than franchising because if
somebody has a complaint it goes to
through Federal process not State
process present of
evil
um the first thing I was going to do is
ask um Mr Hoffman um if he tried to do a
side by side of the abbis version versus
out I tried to do a three column
comparison in as um to keep the font
size legible and to get all three on one
page it it blew up to 90s something
Pages um some of the sections were very
close at the beginning and the end of of
the bill but when you got into the uh
the ru making and some of the little
technical things there were a lot of
things that were similar but they're in
different places so that's a long answer
of I failed well but but that's an
indicator of how many differences there
are between the house version and the
Senate version number one um and the I
guess the other thing I would say is
that if we do away with the version of
the bill with some tweaks for other
things that the house actually
passed there's no guarantee the house is
going to accept the amendment that we
work on they may give it the heave ho
and just go back to the Layon Amendment
because they like it better so by really
deviating from the house position in a
policy way that's also it's a potential
risk I don't know how huge it is but
it's something that um should be
considered and considering the time
frame that we have to turn this around I
just think the hurdle is too big and I
should just say I I'm not even sure
whether I like the franchise or the
licensing model better but I think I
don't have enough time to and I'm not
sure we have enough time to do all that
filtering out in our head and I do not
believe that the Senate uh won't feel
free to mess around with the bill once
it gets over there but at least things
we really care about are in the house
version so we have a leg to stand on
when it goes over
there representative Sweeney thank you
thank you Mr chairman I get it everyone
I do want to reiterate representative
McGuire's comments and just add the
agency model based on the sources that
we had in front of us is Dead on Arrival
in the C
and won't see the light of day and then
we scratch off legalization for this
year potentially have a governor next
year that's not in favor of legalization
and so the window for legalization or to
build up the model in New Hampshire
before it's federally legalized is gone
and then we'll just be thrown to the
Wild Wild West I think we can vote and
be purists on what we want and similar
to the discussions we had on the budget
last year if we all wrote Our Own budget
there' be 400 different budgets in the
house if there if we all wrote Our Own
cannabis bill there'd likely be 400 well
there'd probably be 130 no legalization
and then 270 whatever model works for
that individual
representative I think realism and the
ability to have influence on the
financial model of the franchise model
is our best course of action as the
finance committee because if there were
to be a legalization bill that became
law it would would be the franchise
model and I have no doubt in that and I
think anyone that's paying attention if
the Senate can takes our bill and amends
it to the franchise model if it's not
Dead on Arrival and it was a bluff then
it's going to be the franchise model
that comes to either a concurrence Vote
or a committee a conference vote and I
have a feeling at that State in June
it's probably just going to be
concurrence of the house so I think we
owe it to the house in June to analyze
the financial aspects of the franchise
model today let's go through the
penalties the funds The Liquor
Commission budget atc's transfers
reporting licensing appeal schools let's
go through all of those functions of the
franchise model let's fully analyze the
financials of it let's get updated
fiscal notes I think we can spend the
afternoon put together a working
Amendment and and strike out parts of of
the Maguire Amendment and add things in
that I'm sure representative Maguire
wants as well uh and make it working so
that Tuesday morning we can adopt new
amendment to this um I think we owe it
not only to the the house to on the
financial side of things but I think we
owe it to ourselves so that's my that's
my pitch I think we we should be
realists on this and we should be
realists as to where this is going and
not stick to to what we all may
individually
want represent McGuire thank you Mr
chairman so um two representative
grass's point about the federal um
connection I tend to Discount that
testimony because I think it's
self-serving from people that want um uh
they want the agency they want to run
agencies and
um it just doesn't make sense to me that
the federal
government could go after individual
businesses arbitrarily not just in this
state but anywhere they want to versus
they decide oh the state you know they'd
rather go against the state I mean that
that doesn't make sense to me um you
know I don't think our federal
delegation would sit for it and things
like that um but I do think that
representative eel's uh point is very
well taken right I mean it's this is
quick um it's easier to to go with the
house position all that sort of stuff um
that's just a decision we have to make
uh um but you know it's her points were
good okay we do have the Maguire
124h uh seeing no more discussion would
someone like to make a motion are we
just going to sit on this did oh you did
oh I'm sorry Mr okay are we going to
just do raise show of hands or we going
to vote we'll do a raising of hands
so I I apologize to representative
McGuire he moved he moved the amendment
1214 it was seconded by representative
Sweeney seeing no further discussion
when the clerk is ready please call the
RO okay we're
not no hands okay all right then one
second okay
OTP
swing okay um so this is HB
1633 ought to pass on Amendment uh 1214
representative Maguire yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
Representative cambrell
no chair Wier no
the clerk votes no um walner
no grassy no Lehman no so the UT to pass
three
to
139 uh it's the motion's been made by
representative grassy is there a second
second I'm
you yeah welcome to take a look at it
sure
uh and the motion was seconded by I
believe representative eil right so we
have ought to pass on um Amendment
1339 uh representative
Maguire whoops or you want discussion
I'm sorry I
apologize if there's any discussion
representative
Griffin I hate the I I literally hate
the agency model and I think it's going
to be dead on arrival but I do like the
fact that we got all the funds going
into the general
fund and we are financed and I think if
if nothing else this amendment puts
whatever Revenue we have in the general
fund and I and I will support the
amendment for that purpose only thanks
sir any further discussion representing
Kim BR thank you Mr chair yeah I I'm in
principle I'm against the bill but I
believe that this amendment makes it a
amendment seeing no further discussion
Roa
Griffin okay uh representative Maguire
yes representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative camell yes representative
wer
no the clerk votes yes representative
walner
yes representative grassy yes chair
leean yes okay so the motion passes uh 8
to
one all right we'll take a slight break
and wait for representative Leon's
wording I guess it that's all
right what what is her wording about uh
e
some changes I believe
that uh division has U some suggested
changes that we will hear it's a
Amendment
1356 and we've also been given a
more
detailed
change um as well along with that right
um yes thank you Mr chairman um because
I didn't know of what the turnaround
time would be with um OS I printed out
the document that I sent to them with my
changes um what I did is I realized that
there's a lot of question about what is
in the operational choice and what is in
the regulatory Choice um so there are
many things that are operational
decisions that we had put into the
regulation of cannabis section uh 318
F9 this amendment what it does is it
separates out that operational control
because truthfully a lot of this
discussion about franchise or agency um
because at this point free Market's off
the table but between franchise agency
or even state run is operational control
um so by separating those I added the
definition of operational control model
so that everybody knows what they're
talking about with those different
um if my interpretation of those isn't
right then maybe that may be part of our
disagreement about a franchise is where
in the state adopts a franchise or
franchisee relationship with private
businesses licensed by The Liquor
Commission the agency store model which
I still believe is the strongest model
is where the state requires agreement
and compliance from private businesses
granted limited licenses by The Liquor
Commission beyond the traditional health
and safety regulatory role of government
and so to carve that out to make it so
that our discussion of franchise versus
agency model um if that discussion is um
even still alive you would turn to page
um move past the first three pages in
this separate one it's uh has the
operational control of cannabis I have
that in as 318 F 9-a so that everything
didn't need to get reshuffled in the mix
and that separates out um quite a few
sections it's probably easier for me to
run through those changes off of the
leechman one one because we have um or
which wherever you'd like me to do it I
can tell you which sections were moved
out and then um what I think is also
most important because there is that
risk um let's say that we pass this over
to the Senate with the agency model here
and they decide to change that section
the 9A section to be franchise and then
let's say that the federal government
puts in a stay and says that we can't do
the franchise if we were to concur with
them um it adds a sever severability of
operational control so if the
operational control in RSA 318 f9a is
not implemented I put a placeholder date
of June 30th
2026 operational control provided in
that section shall become null and void
and all references to operational
control requirements shall be waved
that's why having the difference between
operational control and Regulatory
control is important we may choose to
change where some of those lines fall uh
but I think it's important to understand
what's operations and what's
regulatory so looking at that um it
basically takes anything where it is
beyond normal regulation this is the one
about choosing the 15 stores that's a
feature of the franchise or agency store
model um that capacity isn't really
basic regulation that's operational
control so that is moved in there the
concentration of stores getting new
stores becomes operational control um
the same as the procedures it would
require a franchise um sorry not a
franchise an agency store to be approved
by the portion of the Liquor Commission
that approves agency stores or franchise
if they were to change it that way first
before they get a license which then
would streamline some of the licensing
process since they've meet met the
requirements for the agency store um I
know it's a little bit more complicated
but when we had that hearing and we
heard about the $5 million computer
system if we don't have operational
control and Regulatory control separate
we're going to be locked into one model
forever
at least if we have these clear lines
between the operational control and the
regulatory control There's an
opportunity for the state to Pivot if
we've adopted the wrong model so um just
essentially it's it's making moving a
lot of those
into into the operational that's where
the restrictions on the logo signage
marketing and display of cannabis and
cannabis products is um it
moves it moves all of those over that
way and honestly I looked at it and I
looked at what if I were
to may have been at the bottom of my
stack if I were to um write it and write
it with a franchise that actually would
require changing the words within the
agency model and then adding a section
where you can set the prices where you
can set employee terms and conditions at
that point let's lay out specifically
what a franchise would do beyond the
agency store model and make that clear
if the Senate were to change it that way
or if there were enough people with the
will to bring an amendment um
either here or on the floor to change
that agency model to a franchise model
because other than interfering with uh
specific prices and some other business
operations the difference between the
difference between them um
becomes becomes a little bit more clear
if we separate out the operational
control otherwise the amendment has
everything else in the amendment that I
brought to you initially it has some
improvements in the definitions because
I had looked at Senate definitions and
it brought some nonsensical ones um that
are nowhere nowhere involved any end of
this chapter so I removed the
unnecessary ones um and most importantly
this amendment has the protections for
the alternative treatment centers so
that they can continue to cultivate
cannabis and they would be able to do
both adult use and um and therapeutic
cannabis at the same location um there's
quite a few of those that are very
important and even if you don't like my
separation of operational control from
regulatory control um I think it would
be necessary to bring back some of those
clarifications that I had brought in
Amendment
1237 so I know I just jumped a lot on
you at the last minute with this but um
I'd be happy to continue to work to make
this correct the um Appropriations that
I have in my Amendment are still the
previous ones that have what's necessary
for the health and human services to
collect their data and what not
obviously those would need to be changed
to coming from liquor funds because it
makes sense
you take send money from one place and
you put it to send money for
questions good job
um is the division prepared to move on
representative Lan's uh proposal
Amendment
1356 can I recommend that movement is
with um incorporating some of those
changes that are inconsistent between
yours and mine that you I was going to
make sure that if this passes I was
going to make sure that Mr Hoffman would
have done it on his own anyway
but okay there's been a motion made by
representative Grassi and I apologize
who seconded representative
Maguire is there any further discussion
can I just ask a question sure yeah um
could you just clarify for us that are
hanging on here by our fingernails how
does this duvail with the amendment that
we just ad adopted of yours to 1633
they're going to have to be combined
this these are different areas so they
will be added to for instance her
Amendment still has General funds for
instance uh funding this U your
microphone not on I can actually I I
went through and made some notes on here
if that' be helpful to know how it
dovetails with that good um so the up on
uh the leechman amendment going until
page two line 32 nothing has changed
until then um that had that section was
changed um some I can I will find the
there the new section I believe was the
annual mandatory training and continuing
education um this is one where I did
strip out several sections because and
sorry and um for sure on page 10 um item
five lines 3 through 7 which is is the
part part of no later than 3 months
after the effective date of this chapter
and quarterly thereafter the commission
shall report to the house Commerce and
consumer affairs committee and the joint
fiscal um that section would need to be
added into mine because that is not in
mine um and that is actually one that um
we probably would want to look to tie in
the um the protective measure that I add
into mine on P page 19 line 31 where if
the operational control is not
implemented on a certain time um perhaps
that should be a vote of those
committees about whether or not the
operational control um seems to be on
track but that that section and then in
the Appropriations I believe the data
collection related to cannabis and
legalization which is Page 11 of the
leechman amendment from 6 to 14 I can
compare and let you know what the
differences are there and then um the
general funds um but my amendment I
don't think touches that section and
then the Appropriations because I have
Appropriations um including positions
that are required for the data
collection but I I think that they I
think that they mesh very well um it's
reports thank you seeing no further
questions when the clerk is ready please
call the role on Amendment uh I know
again who seconded the motion
grassy
Maguire okay so it's um Amendment
1356 H representative Maguire yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative cambrell yes chair Wier
no the clerk votes I uh representative
walner
yes representative grassie yes chair
one all right Mr Hoffman will mesh those
together
appropriately thanks so what we can do
is if it's all right with everyone we'll
vote on the uh bill as amended on Monday
everyone has a chance to look at it over
the weekend we are not going to meet
until 1 o'clock on Monday a couple of
our members had some previous
engagements but we should be able to
move through this pretty quick um
represent Maguire so I handed out a
piece of paper that deals
with I handed out a piece of paper that
is the um liquor commission's request
for
positions uh or or explanation of how
they came up with their fiscal note and
um I'm going to assume that these are
similar in this in this bill do we know
um if if I can comment the fiscal note I
believe was based off of mine there were
three positions on marketing and
advertising that would not be necessary
because my Pro my bill prohibits the
advertising okay um but I wanted to
speak specific to to have us talk at
least about um
enforcement so they want uh
um uniformed law enforcement Essen
eventually um I don't know if they're
all uniform but the 10 law enforcement
officer group two law law enforcement
officers currently as I understand it um
the there's only there's none in the in
HHS with the current enforcement of the
medical um cannabis program so 10 for 15
businesses with with um you know some
handful of Growers and so on seems way
excessive to me
um
yeah and and especially you know hiring
of of law enforcement is you know next
to Impossible right so we do have the
commissioner of the Liquor Commission
here would you like to address
question so yeah so that that one uh
just seems Seems way too high
um
and what I was told I asked this
question of someone of someone else
earlier and it said what they told me
was they intend to uh aggressively go
after um
bootlegging right of of cannabis right
so because this is now a revenue stream
for the state they want to shut down any
you know any outside people but it seems
to me we've been trying that for a long
long long time with with Zero Effect so
you
know I would think that that we we could
greatly reduce that that section of this
no all right you've heard U
representative Maguire's question if you
have any information for us on Monday
that would be great thank
you
one other question and this might be for
representative Lam the
um the other Bill had a section on
transfer Authority and hiring Authority
by The Liquor Commission it suspended
certain
rsas and I want to make sure that those
are not in these um in what we currently
have do you know about that there were
number of different um Personnel hiring
related things that was that in
Amendment 1237 or was that in the bill
is passed by the house I'm not sure it's
it's something I saw in actually
1214 that I was going to bring up let me
see if I can find it here yeah but I
just want to make sure it's not a lot of
the Senate stuff is copied from the from
the house stuff so I just wanted to make
sure it's actually I did did uh I did
the best I could to compare the two um
using find and word and that sort of
thing and most of that seems to come
more from the commission report that was
never adopted as opposed to from the
house house position I did work with
them to adopt as much as I possibly
could from their model uh but there were
some areas where it just didn't
integrate well or I fundamentally had
the problem with them choosing the
setting the
prices okay I I'll have to find it I'll
do a search myself once we have an
electronic ah here it is um it's it's
suspending RSA 9 colon 16a N9 colon 17A
and N9 colon 17
C and is that in 1214 or in which one
1214 but but do you have RSA 9 colon 16
9 colon 17 in yours anywhere let me let
me pull up the bill and that to look for
it sorry and which one so that I can
look sorry
RSA if you could repeat them N9 colon
16- a N9 colon 17- a and N9 colon
17-c those have to do with you you can't
hire people arbitrarily right that you
need you need uh author authorization to
hire people I can answer that question
if You' like yes please uh that section
provided for the commission to be able
to transfer funds is necessary
currently agencies go to the fiscal
committee to uh transfer funds Beyond a
certain
threshold that was in both bills and
representative Lehman's Amendment um
removed that so that transfers will have
to go to the liquor commit uh the fiscal
Griffin I'm a little perplexed here
because we are the finance
committee and there's a lot of money
being
spent with the proposed
bill and we raised some questions I
think uh representative
Maguire raised some questions about
where some of that money's
going and I think we as a committee we
need to spend some time on that so that
uh and I would like to do that before
Monday so we know what we're
funding that actually we spent a lot of
time on policy and models and we haven't
spent any
time really where the 8 million's going
8 million
plus and I think we need to address that
and I was a little surprised that the Le
Mr chairman hopefully you can have some
of that information available to address
representative McGuire and Griffin's
questions as far as some of the expenses
for licensing and enforcement and others
we did get a draft
unapproved for distribution which I
guess was from The Liquor Commission
Mike the fiscal note on the bill as
amended by the house has been updated
with that information provided by The
Liquor Commission typically we will send
out a request for a fiscal note when the
full body adopts an amendment um and
that's that's when The Liquor Commission
will first get the request to prepare um
we can ask sooner and try to put
something together because of the time
crunch here but uh they everything that
they've provided is current as far as
the Amendments that have been
adopted I think representative Maguire
and Griffin ra some interesting points
especially when you've got the Cannabis
group out there and they don't have a
team of investig or law enforcement if
you will is that correct Mike no correct
inspect thank you represent thank you
one of now that we have this language I
can go through and find out what needs
to be funded in this budget cycle so
that we understand what's necessary for
now and what would need to go into place
for the next budget cycle given that
this is mostly going to be Ru making and
setting and establishing the ground
rules because we won't have anybody
licensed or anybody operating until
cycle represent McGuire thank you Mr
chairman let me ask um is the person to
head this
position do we know I think think the
commissioner is going to head the
operations commissioner is that correct
no well but there'll be a deputy right
so right but are those on my question is
are those unclassified or one of them
unclassified or
not they're they're not they're CL
classified positions I see
so it seems to me to be successful full
you need an independent unit
um that that
runs in uh outside of the normal um
Liquor Commission stuff because
otherwise people get get um get pulled
different ways right and and and uh you
know something urgent happens in liquor
and they say well you're not doing
you're not too busy come on over here
and help us with this and so on so I I
tend to think that the the
Cannabis um section needs to be as
independent as possible and therefore
should have kind of a an independent
more independent head so um I tend to
think it should be an unclassified
position
anyway now we'll get some information
for you from Monday as far as some of
those costs okay good representative eil
just changing the subject a little bit
but uh also getting into money I just
want to raise again on page nine of the
original bill which is a million years
ago um and I don't see Miss chaffy here
but this has to do with the misdemeanor
issue and how the third time around that
you're caught smoking the the um penalty
is actually higher than it even is now
in existing law and I remember we talked
about this to some extent and that it
actually is going to put more of an
expense and strain on the judicial
system than what exists right now um so
I just wanted to raise that and see what
that anybody like to comment up
yeah so we do have a question for you we
have not changed the penalty Clause that
came out of house Commerce and I guess
you spoke of your concern that it was a
mror for the Third charge whereas this
proposal from the Senate was the second
offense was of Mr Mina so so um just to
clar thank you representative thank you
very much for the opportunity to speak
to this I think the primary concern is
that the highest penalty is an undefined
MISD meter which means that whoever is
whether it's the the second offense as
it was um in uh representative Maguire's
Amendment or whether or not it's the
third offense as it is in the underlying
Bill HB um
1633 um the concern is that that
misdemeanor shouldn't be undefined mind
it's a very simple Amendment you would
just insert Class B before misdemeanor
just I keep saying two little words and
with those two little words you would no
longer have to find uh fund public
defenders for individuals caught smoking
in public you would bring the penalties
to be much more in line in what the
penalties are now currently if you
possess um less than 34 of an ounce and
are caught smoking in public um and also
would avoid the cost of potentially
housing um people convicted of this
crime for up to a year a year in our
County jails um for the penalty and so
um again it would be a very simple
amendment to fix this issue to a class B
it would still be a crime it would still
be a fine of up to TW um $1,200 for
these individuals so a serious penalty
but but not with the cost Associated of
putting somebody um in
jail represent
would that bring it into line with what
the current decriminalization penalties
are yes sir it would that's I would
highly support that considering that was
my
bill so I'm getting a general okay
from all right Mike if you could change
that I guess it's on page nine line 15
and I had a little B in front of Mr Meer
on line 15 I guess my fault that I
didn't include that in one of my
suggestions so thank you all right thank
sir we'll see you on Monday at 1 a.
you'll have to get up yeah I was just
making sure you're
away all right so oh um
school do we does this bill have
distance from schools or anything like
that um yes I believe this has 1,000
ft
okay you okay with that or I am the
governor's
not he wants 2,000 ft I don't know if
that well then we won't be able to get
one in sale them schools are too closed
right the fiscal note
um your Amendment changed the source of
funds of the
appropriation but as written in the bill
the appropriation from the
fund um does doesn't change the fiscal
impact but where the appropriation comes
from right and the bill lays out the $8
million will cover Administration so the
response that the Liquor Commission gave
us for the bill as amended by the house
which they passed out um last week would
still be current except for the change
in the source of funds yeah that's how I
see it yes yeah so no general fund
direct general fund impact no no Direct
General funding and and Mr chairman I
think representative McGuire did point
out that for 15 stores some of their
position was asking for seemed excessive
but I'd like to have more backup on why
they needed those positions and you know
they're hiring a Human Service person
you Human Services person seems like why
but you
know well the I believe the commissioner
of the Liquor Commission is here and
taken all those questions under
[Music]
my
e